[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver sur public sénat cet après
midi pour suivre les travaux de la haute
assemblée avec une nouvelle audition de
la commission d' enquête sur la gestion
de la crise du coronavirus les sénateurs
réunissent les différentes professions
de santé qui ont été mobilisés pendant
l'épidémie
l'occasion de faire le point sur leur
organisation leur coordination
au plus fort de la crise au printemps
dernier je vous laisse écouter cette
audition rien que la vérité levé la main
droite et dit je le jure je jure très
bien isabelle de rands 1 j'ai prêté
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité ait levé la main droite et dit
je jure je le jure serge fournier prêté
serment dire la vérité toute la vérité
levé la main droite et dire je le jure
je le jure pascal mathieu dire la vérité
toute la vérité levé la main droite et
dit je le jure je le jure l'écart
involve talent traiter également serment
de dire la vérité toute la vérité rien
que la vérité levé la main droite et
jure jean-marcel mourgues même démarche
la vérité toute la vérité levé la main
droite et dit je le jure je le jure
merci je vous rappelle également que le
port du masque est obligatoire même en
s'exprimant et je vous remercie bien
entendu pour cette vigilance
ceci dit je passe la parole
ma foi dans l'ordre démunis
d'énumération si vous en êtes d'accord
donc président sur vos redon c'est à
vous merci déjà merci de nous inviter à
nous exprimer sur cette problématique du
coc vide juste brièvement parce que je
tiendrais pas ces minutes j'ai vraiment
pris de court pour le coup j'attendais
que mes camarades commence par dire pour
peut copier les idées mais
l'ordre infirmier c'est d'après
l'adresse 700 mille professionnels et
serait alors 350 mineurs toujours une
difficulté
je pense qu'on a quand même une une
vraie représentativité à chaque fois
qu'on fait des enquêtes on a des
réponses et 5 atteints étaient
disponibles sur 350 sur 710 1000
répondants 48 heures à chaque fois donc
on a fait beaucoup d'inquièter pas notre
période là on a la particularité mais
d'avoir à peu près un tiers de libéro
deux tiers de salariés publics et privés
inscrit un autre tableau et avec des
professionnels qui durant toute la prise
people tout à perdre coville on
continuer à se rendre au domicile
assurer la continuité des soins puisque
il n'y a pas eu d'interruption même
d'après les chiffres de la cnam les
infirmiers ont continué à être présent
en libéral donc avec une forte prise en
charge patients déjà co vide et dans les
idées au secteur hospitalier où on a eu
toutes les images largement diffusées à
la télé de mobilisation et de transfert
d'infirmier au travers différentes
régions pour renforcer les services de
réanimation
voilà je ne dirais pas plus un propos
liminaire et après je réponds aux
questions dans la mesure où je serais
interrogé merci isabelle de rands 1 g
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président mesdames les sénatrices et
messieurs les sénateurs mesdames
messieurs chers collègues
merci de me permettre de représenter les
24000 sages-femmes de france la france a
traversé traverse sa plus grande crise
sanitaire depuis plus d'un siècle faut
lutter contre la copie 19 des mesures
exceptionnelles ont été prises le monde
s'est confiné le système de santé s'est
réorganisée et l'industrie c'est aussi
réorientés
pendant cette période hors du commun les
sages femmes ont continué leurs
activités à les questions telles fermer
leur cabinet je peux répondre d'ores et
déjà non malgré des conditions
particulièrement complexes
alors que la crise sanitaire a imposé
une interruption de l'activité médicale
non urgentes dans son ensemble il est
essentiel de souligner que l'obstétrique
ne se déprogramme pas et defacto ne se
reporte pas je veux profiter de cette
occasion pour remercier mes consoeurs
les sages-femmes et saluer leur
professionnalisme sans faille
il est indispensable à d'exposer les
comptes
on complexe dans lequel les sages femmes
ont été amenées à exercer
pourquoi pour répondre aux conditions de
crise actuelle mais pour répondre aussi
aux prochaines crises sanitaires et
améliorer la prise en charge de la santé
des femmes tout d'abord l'accès aux
équipements de protection individuelle a
été chaotique et cacophonique pour
l'ensemble des professionnels de santé
encore plus pour les sages-femmes le 28
février le conseil national de l'ordre a
alerté les autorités de santé sur les
problématiques d'accès au matériel de
protection pour les sages-femmes et a
reçu une réponse rassurante
le 28 février le 14 mars un arrêté a été
effectivement publiées permettant aux
sages femmes de bénéficier de stocks
nationaux au même titre que les autres
professionnels de santé
ce même arrêté à vue un contre ordre 48
heures plus tard un nouvel arrêté est
venu le contredire omettant les sages
femmes
le conseil national a alors saisi en
urgence le cabinet du ministre et la dgs
pour rectification le soir même un
message dgs urgent était publié
néanmoins cette dotation est symbolique
car à ce moment là ne comprend que si
masques par semaine pour les
sages-femmes exerçant uniquement dans
les zones à risque pour rappel le haut
conseil de santé publique avait classé
les femmes enceintes troisième trimestre
de la grossesse comme patient d'une
érables et cela dès le 14 mars
pour rappel et pour répondre à la
question préalable les sages femmes
n'ont pas interrompu leur activité
pour rappel celle-ci ont été amenés à
prendre en charge des patientes qu'ovide
cette dotation de 6 masques ne s'est
étendue à l'ensemble des sages-femmes
pour le territoire français que le 25
mars
la dotation est passé à 18 masquer le 20
avril puis à 24 masque au moment des
coups fumants cela par semaine bien
évidemment pas par jour aussi au plus
fort de la crise les sages femmes n'ont
eu accès qu'à un nom plus que restreint
de masques marginalisant la profession
et par extension la santé des femmes
ajoutons qu'aujourd'hui encore les sages
femmes ne bénéficient toujours pas de
masques ffp2 pour prendre en charge les
femmes coït plus par ailleurs la prise
en compte de la périnatalité par les
pouvoirs publics a été tardive
les sages-femmes et les maternités se
sont organisés en conséquence
difficilement avec des protocoles
aléatoire
la question de la place de
l'accompagnant pendant l'accouchement a
crispé les débats et stressés les femmes
des couples les réponses rapides pour
les paires inutilité ont été publiés
tardive non seulement le 1er avril
de plus ces réponses rapides n'ont pas
été actualisés au moment capital du
déconfinement en raison d'un blocage lié
à la stratégie de dotation en masques
ffp2 pour les sages-femmes
de plus un aspect plus générale dans la
gestion de la crise a été la
communication si l'exercice de
communication du ministère de la santé
était difficile du fait de la
progression rapide de l'épidémie et de
l'évolution quotidienne des
connaissances il est devenu quasiment
impossible la confusion de communication
politique publique scientifique a
conduit à la cacophonie à la perte de
repères et à la décrédibilisation de la
parole publique
dans ce contexte l'ordre des sages
femmes tant au niveau national que local
s'est organisé pour soutenir et gérer
les sages femmes dans leurs pratiques
afin de garantir une prise en charge
sécurisé de qualité des femmes et des
nouveau nés mais également défendre les
droits des femmes l'ordre à participer à
la régulation des pratiques dès le 15
mars
nous avons adopté des consignes
gouvernementales recommandons
sages-femmes de maintenir leur activité
tout en reportant certains soins non
urgents
nous avons publié un guide de bonnes
pratiques toujours en vigueur dans le
cadre du déconfinement dès le début de
la crise la principale du ciel de
l'ordre a été la communication devant
des informations évolutive et parfois
contradictoires afin de limiter la
confusion le conseil a choisi temporisé
recouper centraliser les informations
provenant de différentes sources
ainsi nous avons mis en place une
communication multimodal pour informer
directement l'ensemble des sages-femmes
denquête flash du collège national des
sages-femmes de juillet 2020 les
newsletters de l'ordre et les
communiqués dgs urgents ont été les
principales sources d'information des
sages-femmes pour l'ensemble de la
communauté
l'ordre a joué un rôle de veille et
alerte à destination des autorités en
relayant les demandes des craintes les
questions des sages femmes
par exemple nous sommes intervenus pour
obtenir le remboursement la télémédecine
ou comme décrit auparavant pour obtenir
des dotation d'équipements de protection
historiquement engagés pour défendre les
droits des femmes
lord s'est mobilisée pour augmenter les
délais légaux alliés d'accès a dirigé
pendant la crise
les droits des femmes ne doivent pas
reculer les sages femmes ont contribué à
maintenir l'accès à la contraception ali
vg afin de garantir aux femmes la
possibilité de disposer de leur corps
durant la phase aiguë de la crise les
sages femmes ont un vrai sans ménagement
dans des conditions complexes
quotidienne ainsi elles ont accompagné
et là encore une fois jory terre à la
question de la fermeture des cabinets et
la baisse d'activité elles ont
accompagné près de cent vingt 120 mille
naissances pendant ces deux mois de
confinement l'activité obstétricale ne
se déprogramme pas fatigué par la crise
sanitaire et leur marginalisation dans
la gestion de cette crise il faut
conclure un jeu conclu
la lassitude et sasha met aujourd'hui
renforcée par les conclusions du secteur
de la santé
elles se sentent plus que jamais oublié
et méprisés par les pouvoirs publics
merci votre attention
si monsieur le président du conseil
national de l'ordre des dentistes
merci monsieur le président en ce qui
nous concerne
cette crise a appris un aspect
particulier ceci pour deux paramètres
le premier c'est que nous étions et nous
sommes toujours
l'une où la profession la plus exposée
au risque de contamination est le
deuxième paramètre c'est que nous avons
la particularité d'avoir un exercice qui
est à 95% d'ordre libéral j'ai été un
des présidents qui le 16 mars a demandé
à l'ensemble de la profession de fermer
les cabinets pour des raisons de
sécurité et parallèlement l'ordre
national et les ordres régionaux et
départementaux ont instauré un service
de garde sur le territoire métropole et
outre mer
nous avons mis en place également les ça
a été la première fois par rapport à
d'autres d'autres professions numéros
d'appels de service de garde nationale
et je dois dire que cette crise on a
parfaitement bien ressenti que tout a
reposé sur les ordres qui ont assuré en
totale autonomie
la gestion de la crise
voilà ce que je voulais dire en
introduction et évidemment nous ne
manquerons pas de de répondre à toutes
les questions qui seront posées et nous
avons dans d'autres interventions un
certain nombre de choses à dire
notamment sur la gestion de la crise par
les pouvoirs publics
par ailleurs nous l'avons signalé
monsieur le président nous n'avons pas
de diaporama vous présenter mais nous
avons donné un lien qui vous donne accès
donc à la dernière revue que nous avons
fait ou toute l'histoire de la crise a
été parfaitement retracé par moi même et
mes secrétaires généraux je vous
remercie monsieur merci puisque nous
acceptons effectivement les documents
n'hésitez pas à nous en donner ça
enrichit notre réflexion
mathieu donc pour les masseurs
kinésithérapeutes cinq minutes si vous
le souhaitez merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
chers collègues mesdames messieurs je
suis très honoré d'être auditionnés dans
le cadre de cette commission denquête
parce que il me sens fondamental de
faire part à la représentation nationale
de ce que nous avons traversée nous en
tant que organisateurs si je puis
m'exprimer ainsi de nos professions
respectives puisqu'il y a eu des moments
où on s'est senti bien seul et notamment
au début de la crise si l'on peut
comprendre que comme l'a dit une de mes
collègues la crise était évolutive et
qu'il fallait s'adapter jour après jour
ce qu'a dû faire le ministère de la
santé par exemple
force est de constater que très souvent
nous avons dû être les relais vers nos
membres
faute d'information j'en veux pour
preuve l'hygiène dans les cabinets tout
au début de la crise bien avant que la
dgs nous donne des renseignements
il a fallu que nous nous débrouillons
tout seul pour donner des consignes
claires à nos membres
puisque aucune était disponible et moi
même je m'étais rapproché de la société
française d'hygiène hospitalière
parce que je ne trouvais pas de
ressources si bien que ce sont les
ordres quand même qu'ils ont vu le je
dirais leur rôle renforcé et réaffirmer
vis-à-vis nos membres
puisqu'on était un petit peu les
boussoles dans la crise vers lesquels
ils se sont tournés et l'ordre des
kinésithérapeutes ont envoyé des
newsletters pluri hebdomadaire des flash
actu chaque fois que nous avions des
renseignements nous mettions nos sites à
jour et nous avons dû traiter des
centaines et des centaines faim des
milliers de questions écrites par
internet
nous avons fait des facebook live nous
avons dû communiquer énormément parce
que les professionnels étaient perdus
donc les kinésithérapeutes c'est
93 700 professionnels dont 79 1800
libéraux nous avons pris la décision au
moins dans les deux premières semaines
du confinement de demander la fermeture
des cabinets ce qui n'est en aucun cas
l'arrêt des soins puisque nous avons
recommandé à nos membres de poursuivre
les soins à domicile
nan reportables et les soins urgents et
nous leur avons demandé de décider par
eux-mêmes des soins qu'ils devaient
mettre en oeuvre juste un exemple une
entorse de cheville n'est pas une
urgence mais une entorse de cheville
chez un patient porteur d'un parkinson
en perte d'autonomie ça peut être une
urgence si bien que nous avons donné
cette consigne
pourquoi parce que si nous considérons
ne serait ce que dix actes par jour x 79
1800 libéraux eh bien on est à quasiment
huit cent mille personnes qui se
déplacent en période de confinement ça
n'était pas raisonnable et nous a paru
nécessaire d'adapter nos consignes que
nous avons élargi au bout de deux
semaines puisque attendre deux semaines
pour certains accès possible et un peu
plus c'est difficile
cette crise a mis en exergue que
plusieurs choses que je dénonce depuis
des années c'est à dire le manque de
kinésithérapeute dans les établissements
de santé
j'ai d'ailleurs pris l'initiative
d'écrire à la commission des affaires
sociales du sénat et de vous alerter
tout au début de la crise en vous disant
que la prise en charge des patients
seraient compromises et je pense qu'elle
l'a été non pas en réanimation parce que
là on trouve des kinésithérapeutes
mais comme on a organisé des sorties
rapides qui de des patients des
réanimations quand il y avait trop de
bousculades si je peux m'exprimer ainsi
vers les services
nous savons que les soins n'ont pas été
de qualité ou comme ils auraient dû
l'être en raison de manque de
kinésithérapeute dans les services nous
avons été exclus des ehpad très tôt dès
le mois de janvier et j'ai alerté les
pouvoirs publics les fédérations d pad
et je suis très inquiète parce que pour
sauver des vies on a compromis
l'autonomie de nombreux patients et ça
ça ne se voit pas et je suis sûr qu'il y
à des patients qui sont morts n'ont pas
dû qu'au vide mais des conséquences de
la sédentarité et de l'absence de
de kinésithérapie dans les services et
j'attire votre attention sur le fait que
par exemple la rs occitanie j'ai dû
intervenir cette semaine avait donné la
consigne déjà de d'empêcher les
kinésithérapeutes d'accéder aux ehpad
cette semaine donc j'ai l'impression que
on repas alors même que certains
médecins coordonnateurs demandé au
kinésithérapeute devenir leur téléphoner
il se voyait refuser l'entrée par les
directeurs donc ça c'est quelque chose
d'extra tout au long de la crise et
encore maintenant ça repart
nous avons dû intervenir auprès du
ministère de la santé que j'ai eus qui a
réagi tout de suite et de la rs
occitanie qui a dit que c'était une
serbe sur interprétations des consignes
du ministère donc là on est devant un
réel une réelle difficulté
je ne reviendrai pas sur les masques ma
collègue sage femme a eu une
présentation exhaustive nous étions dans
les mêmes conditions c'est-à-dire si
masques par semaine ce qui était
ingérable et nous avons eu des grandes
difficultés par exemple des écoles
refuser les enfants kinésithérapeute
parce qu'il était dans la liste il y
avait des points de suspension n'y avait
pas écrit spécifiquement tous les
professionnels de santé
donc nous étions dans des situations
très compliquées et j'avoue que nous
avons pu nous appuyer beaucoup pour les
masques sur beaucoup de maires beaucoup
de présidents de départements
quelques rs il faut bien le dire mais
lorsque nous avions des relations
privilégiées avec elle quand on les
connaissait personnellement par exemple
mais en tout cas on n'a plus beaucoup
s'appuyer sur les acteurs locaux plus
que sur les ars et ça c'est important de
le souligner je crois et je suis à votre
disposition pour toute question
nécessaire
monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
mesdames et messieurs l'ordre des
médecins représente 103 107 mille
médecins dont 198 milles un peu plus en
activité régulière et 18000 en cumul
emploi-retraite à peu près à parts
égales entre ceux qui ont une activité
salariée notamment hospitalière et ceux
qui ont une activité libérale que l'on
appelle communément médecine de ville
avec une parité à présent entre nos
consoeurs et nos confrères pour être
synthétique dans le propos en ces
quelques minutes je vais séparer un
trois phases dans cette pandémie avec
des relevés d'observations des constats
et des griefs qui parfois se recoupent
et qui parfois sont spécifiques à
chacune des périodes avant le
confinement on peut dire et c'est un
constat commun qu'il y avait une
impréparation de la france à ce risque
sanitaire de cette pandémie
malgré pourtant des rapports qui ont été
peu lui quant à la forte augmentation
ces quarante dernières années des zones
aux c'est à dire des pathologies
transmissible de l'animal à l'homme
pendant cette décennie faut-il rappeler
la diminution par 10 des moyens de
protection que sont les masques une
dépendance accrue vis-à-vis de ses
moyens de protection dorénavant est très
fortement fabriqués à l'étranger et
aussi des médicaments essentiels
notamment dans la sphère de la
réanimation et enfin les tests très
notoirement insuffisant qui ont été
ciblés pour le seul traçage des clusters
comme si les clusters et leur
surveillance n'était pas appelé à
pouvoir être un contrôle et un moment où
l'autre et tous a largement contribué à
ce que la france dans les pays qui ont
des registres d'un mortalité fiable soit
hélas parmi les pays en tête au début de
cette pandémie
la deuxième phase c'est pendant le conte
finement on a parlé de résilience du
système de santé
mais en fait on devrait plutôt parler de
formidable adaptation dans l'urgence des
professionnels de santé qui ont su
casser les barrières tant sur le plan de
l'organisation que de leur pratique que
de leurs horaires pour permettre
d'absorber un tout le surcroît de
patients atteints de cette pandémie
mais c'est aussi un système qui a montré
ses faiblesses en particulier pour des
raisons d'organisation l'insuffisance
d'implication hélas des établissements
de santé privés et de la médecine de
ville
vous l'avez évoqué monsieur le président
dans vos propos introductif et cette
période a aussi montré une
désorganisation profonde du système de
santé
orco vide faut-il rappeler l'annulation
massive de consultation et de soins
programmés les difficultés aggravées de
l'accès aux soins est pour mémoire début
juillet 80% des consultations qui avait
été annulée n'avait toujours pas été
refixé et c'est ainsi qu'on peut parler
d'une perte de chance dans le suivi des
pathologies graves tels que des cancers
ou chroniques et madame mathieu l'a
évoqué aussi pour les personnes âgées
on peut dire aussi que pendant ce
confinement il ya une confusion dans
l'information avec des responsabilités
partagées
certes la parole des scientifiques dont
celle des médecins dans les médias a
parfois été inaudible et contradictoires
celle aussi des agences régionales de
santé vis-à-vis des professionnels de
santé qui parfois été mieux informé par
la presse générale que par lesdites
agences troisième période
celle du déconfinement qui montre quoi
des difficultés à retrouver un
fonctionnement antérieur du système de
santé des incertitudes dans
l'anticipation opérationnel s'il y avait
une deuxième vague d'importance ce qui
est toujours craint notamment cet
automne
une mise en lumière particulièrement
crues des insuffisances du système de
santé avec toutes les incertitudes quant
aux mesures du ségur de l'os de la santé
dont chacun s'accorde à dire qu'elles
sont notoirement insuffisantes
même si celles ci sont encore récente le
manque de transversalité dans le système
de santé de coordination et des agences
régionales de santé qui ont été trop des
agences de déconcentration plutôt que
des agences de décentralisation je
n'oublierai pas la protection des
soignants qui a été notoirement
insuffisantes et qui a probablement
expliqué largement des messages de santé
publique où on jetait disons l'anathème
en tout cas le peu d'intérêt en ce qui
concerne pouvoirs publics sur l'intérêt
du port de masques diamétralement
opposés à ceux qui heureusement sont
tenues aujourd'hui je parlerai aussi de
l'insuffisance de concertation dans une
dit démocratie sanitaire
lol les ordres ont par exemple étaient
absents des comités scientifiques alors
que nous avions aussi des questions
éthiques notamment vis-à-vis de la prise
en charge des personnes âgées en ehpad
et donc in globo une prise en charge qui
nous a semblé beaucoup trop
administrative et pas suffisamment
inclusive dans ce que les ordres de
professionnels de santé celui des
médecins notamment par leur engagement
leur représentativité de l'ensemble des
professionnels inscrits au tableau et
les questions éthiques aurait pu
apporter
merci merci paul et pharmaciens madame
la présidente je lui ce président
mesdames messieurs les rapporteurs
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
merci pour effectivement nous donnait la
parole alors dès le début de la crise
sanitaire au même titre que l'ensemble
des professionnels de santé les
pharmaciens de tous les métiers se sont
mobilisés activement pour répondre donc
aux enjeux de santé publique
les pharmaciens ont été en première
ligne avec la population malgré le
confinement il faut rappeler en effet la
fermeture de la plupart des commerces
qui est intervenue le 15 mars et le
confinement de la population le 17 mars
et que les pharmaciens d'officine et les
laboratoires de biologie médicale sont
toujours restés ouverts depuis lors
parfois seuls professionnels de santé
accessibles à la population pour
répondre aux questions de la population
inquiète et angoissé par le climat de
temps démis tous les pharmaciens ont
rempli leur mission de santé publique
sans surenchère sans céder à la
cacophonie ou au doute qui a parfois
prévalu sur certains sujets
les pharmaciens ont contribué à
surmonter cette crise sanitaire
quelle que soit l'activité exercée et
dans un seul but celui de garantir la
continuité des soins fabricants
distributeurs en gros pharmaciens
exerçant en officine ou dans les
établissements de santé pharmaciens
biologistes pharmaciens réservistes tous
ont oeuvré pour la santé publique
le contexte était difficile et inédits
chaque conseiller ordinal étaient
présents d'abord sur son lieu d'exercice
pour exercer son métier mais aussi pour
soutenir les confrères qui devait faire
face comme cela a été exprimé non
seulement à une situation exceptionnelle
mais aussi à des violences verbales mais
aussi physique le jeu tient à votre
disposition le nombre d'agressions
déclaré auprès des confrères notamment
officinaux et aussi des escroqueries sur
la vente de masques notamment et autres
sollicitations d'escrocs bien sûr les
pharmaciens ont dû également s'adapter
quotidiennement de nouveaux modes
d'organisation faire face par exemple à
des équipes réduites au sein des
officines
parce que d'abord le personnel je tiens
aussi elle rappelé des pharmaciens et de
ses équipes n'avaient pas de masque plus
que les autres professionnels de santé
qu'il a fallu mettre en place l'accueil
du public dans les officines pareil sous
l'égide de l'ordre qui donnait là aussi
des guides et des recommandations
et puis un évidemment
des règles de dispensation qu'il a fallu
adapter tout au long de la crise avec
des mesures exceptionnelles pour là
encore garantir la continuité des soins
garantir le bon usage des médicaments on
pourra revenir sur l'épisode hydroxyque
eurokin mais aussi faire face au risque
de pénurie sur tous ces sujets l'ordre a
été partenaire des pouvoirs publics afin
encore une fois que garantir l'accès aux
soins
sans oublier le le rôle qui a été donnée
aux offices aux officinaux et la mission
de recueillir les violences conjugales
sollicité par le ministère de
l'intérieur puisque les officines ont
servi de lieux d'accueil des personnes
victimes de violence familiale parce
qu'encore une fois dans ce temps où
beaucoup de lieux étaient fermés les
officines ont servi de relais puisque
ces agressions ont malheureusement
beaucoup augmenté pendant cette période
bien sûr on aura l'occasion de revenir
sur la distribution des masques du stock
et à puisque là c'est l'ordre des
pharmaciens qui s'est porté volontaire
auprès du ministère pour aider les
autorités à acheminer les masques du
stock et à vers les professionnels de
santé de ville
une mission que les pharmaciens ont
accepté et relevé je dirais vaillamment
parce que c'était pas simple et voilà ça
a été très compliqué à gérer
je voudrais aussi évoqué les pharmaciens
de pharmacie à usage intérieur dont on a
peu parlé parce qu'on a beaucoup parlé
des lits de réanimation qui étaient
ouverts mais ces lits de réanimation
n'aurait pas été armés sans la présence
des pharmaciens dans les hôpitaux qui
ont dû là encore aussi faire des
prouesses pour armer ces lits de
réanimation
bien sûr les biologistes très rapidement
concernés pour mettre en place
évidemment les solutions de dépistage et
de diagnostic dans le contexte dans
lequel nous nous situons au coeur de la
crise sanitaire en plein confinement les
pouvoirs publics ont dû gérer en urgence
la pénurie des masques donc les
pharmaciens ont encore une fois relevé
cette mission
difficile tout très tôt l'ordre a
souhaité donc collaborer avec les
ministères et les autres sur les autres
sujets notamment sur la mise en place de
mesures pour
préserver l'accès aux soins je vais pas
vous faire la liste là je la tiens à
votre disposition mais vous la
connaissez vous en avez probablement
déjà entendu parler le renouvellement
des ordonnances le circuit ville hôpital
de distribution des médicaments
rétrocédés la préparation des solutions
hydro alcooliques et des gels hydro
alcooliques les restrictions sur les
prescriptions hydroxy chloroquine le
paracétamol qui a été limité aussi pour
éviter les ruptures
l'accès les mesures exceptionnelles de
l'accès aux médicaments de libérer
médicamenteuse
les médicaments de rede réanimation où
là encore il a fallu faire un circuit
adapté
voilà donc mission nombreuses la
principale préoccupation qui m'anime
c'est la préservation de la santé
publique tout faire pour la santé des
soignants et celle des patients qui
venaient tous les jours à l'officine car
les pharmaciens ont toujours été en
première ligne et ont toujours répondu
présent quelles que soient les
circonstances
je suis extrêmement fier du comportement
de tous les pharmaciens et je tiens à
les en remercier
durant cette crise ils ont été à la
hauteur des enjeux et des
responsabilités que l'on attendait d'eux
et qui très souvent dépassait largement
le cadre habituel de leur activité je
tiens à souligner l'investissement très
important des conseillers ordinaux et là
aussi je les en remercie
dans l'accompagnement des confrères pour
l'exercice de leur activité
je souhaite que ces enquêtes
parlementaires soit l'opportunité de
faire des propositions constructives
temps sur l'évolution de nos exercices
professionnel que sur nos relations avec
les pouvoirs publics afin que si une
nouvelle crise sanitaire
nous devions faire face et bien les
choses soient plus claires sur le rôle
de l'ordre ce que nous pouvons apporter
aux pouvoirs publics et j'espère que ça
sera l'occasion d'en des prochains
textes de loi peut-être de mettre en
place des choses je vous remercie
merci vous pouvez compter sur nous le
rappelle fss très rapidement et c'est
donc tu ne sont bien sûr au rendez vous
je vais donc passer la parole vaut aux
rapporteurs qui vont s'exprimer on nous
allons commencer par sylvie vermeillet
cet après midi merci monsieur le
président merci mesdames et messieurs
pour vos expressions liminaire j'aurai
une question précise à poser à monsieur
le vice président du conseil national de
l'ordre des médecins
suite à l'audition de ce matin dans le
cadre de notre commission denquête nous
avons été destinataires d'un mail du 20
mars 2020 qui émanait du l'ordre des
médecins du vaucluse se mêle du 20 mars
a pour objet donc une information
coville 19 à diffuser à tous les
confrères du département et je vais vous
lire une petite partie là l'introduction
précise que le poste médical avancé va
être montée sur l'hôpital permettant de
faire le tri adapté des patients avant
d'entrer dans l'enceinte de celui ci je
passe trois petites lignes et un
paragraphe précise que malheureusement
au vu des dernières recommandations les
patients des maisons de retraite ehpad
présentant des comorbidités est en
détresse respiratoire ne seront bientôt
plus admissible à l'hôpital
il devra être envisagée pour eux des
soins de confort
nous avons conscience que ces choix
éthique à venir seront douloureux mais
inévitable nour et aborderont bien
entendu ce sujet prochainement
alors monsieur le vice-président est ce
que vous avez eu connaissance de ce mail
est ce que au titre de votre ordre
est ce que vous y avez réagi est ce qu'à
votre connaissance d'autres départements
ou adopté la même position
et au final est ce que l'ordre des
médecins à ce que le conseil national de
l'ordre des médecins valider cette
disposition qui malheureusement exposé
que les patients des maisons de retraite
et des ehpad ne serait plus admissible à
l'hôpital parce qu' est-ce que je dois
comprendre par ce mail en tout cas que
le conseil national aurait cautionné
cette disposition
madame la rapporteure je vous remercie
très sincèrement de votre question
l'ordre national des médecins a eu
connaissance de ce mail
et autant dire les choses très
clairement
c'était une crainte de l'ensemble de la
communauté des soignants que la
situation française ne devienne à
l'identique de la situation vécue en
italie fort heureusement même si on
attend jantes et les capacités maximales
de réanimation celles ci n'ont pas tout
à fait été atteinte et avec la
formidable résilience de femmes et
d'hommes professionnels de santé qui ont
su ouvrir des lits supplémentaires faire
y compris des transferts sanitaires on a
évité cette situation qui aurait été sur
un plan éthique tout à fait
catastrophique
le conseil national s'est exprimée par
communiqué de presse tout à fait
clairement pour condamner tout rick
lioret mais qui fort heureusement a été
évité il n'y a aucune ambiguïté là
dessus ça a été évitée en revanche
conformément hors de la pandémie à ce
qu'il est communément admis par les
collèges et sociétés savantes
d'anesthésistes et de réanimateurs
la réanimation a été fait sur des
personnes en fonction de leur état de
santé et leur vulnérabilité
sans que les soignants ne soit accusé
d'acharnement thérapeutique
déraisonnable mais je peux vous garantir
que la situation où des personnes âgées
notamment vivant en ehpad n'aurait pas
eu les soins auxquels il avait
naturellement droit a pu être évité et
j'en remercie très sincèrement
l'ensemble des soignants
merci c'est clair s'il vit très bien
bernard jomier merci monsieur vrai dire
merci à vos six pour vos exposé
liminaire j'ai une question à vous poser
à tous les six mais qui nécessite une
réponse par oui ou par non feint une
réponse très brève est ce qu'avant dans
la première période d'épidémie avant
l'acmé de l'épidémie qui est survenu
vers le 10 15 avril de mémoire vous avez
été associé à l'élaboration de
référentiels de prise en charge des
patients avez vous eu des contacts ce
que vous avez eu helmand avec les
membres du cabinet ou de la djs avec
lesquels vous êtes en contact
habituellement pourparlers pour échanger
autour de l'épidémie de deux pots vides
et puis j'aurai une question pour
l'ordre des médecins on a on a débattu
ce matin on s'est interrogé lors de
notre réflexion avec nos intervenants
sur l'éthique médicale sur ce qui a été
la parole des médecins pendant cette
crise ses côtés contradictoires alors
variés qui sont bien normal si l'on
d'une profession qui elle même est et
diverses et qui est qu'il ya une
pluralité d'expression
est ce que l'ordre des médecins estime
qui a eu dans cette séquence des
infractions à la déontologie
où est l'éthique médicale y at il des
procédures qui sont en cours oui ou non
nous estime lambert estime t-il qu on
est resté dans le cadre de la
controverse scientifique
qui est un élément normal normale du
débat et puis dernière question pour
l'ordre des dentistes
avez vous des regrets de votre décision
d'abord conseillé demandé la fermeture
des cabinets dentaires
et alors monsieur le rapporteur en ce
qui concerne les référentiels de prise
en charge autant que je sache en ce qui
concerne les référentiels médicaux il
n'y a pas eu de contact direct avec
l'ordre national pour autant je veux
quand même nuancer la critique que j'ai
pu apporter bise avant des bises à vis
des agences régionales de santé
certaines d'entre elles ont fait un
travail remarquable et notamment pour
répondre
madame le rapporteur à ce que nous
disions il ya quelques minutes la
gestion par la rs ile-de-france pour
éviter effectivement une submersion des
moyens a été tout à fait louer à sa
juste mesure
et effectivement il faut pas faire une
critique en règle
voilà alors ce qui concerne la parole
des médecins on est dans une situation
complexe complètement inédite puisque
cette pandémie
la dernière référence c'est la grippe
dite espagnole
un siècle plus tôt il n'y avait pas de
médias la presse écrite
donc là on est effectivement dans une
effervescence médiatique qui a été
absolument pas connu à l'époque
et force est de constater que le temps
scientifique n'est pas le temps humain
il n'est pas le temps la communication
la science est évolutive par nature elle
est faite de doutes avant confirmation
ou infirmation pour autant il faut un
respecter l'expression de chat
cain sans pour autant faire la promotion
de thérapeutique déraisonnable n'en ai
prouvé ou qui exposerait à une
dangerosité particulière vis-à-vis de
patients donc je ne suis pas là pour
faire publicité sur tel ou tel médecin
ou telle ou telle procédure en cours
mais les choses suivent leur rythme avec
effectivement des auditions de certains
médecins auprès de conseils
départementaux de l'ordre des médecins
et cela pourra effectivement se traduire
le cas échéant au cas par cas par des
traductions chambre disciplinaire de
première instance
si monsieur fourni oui merci monsieur le
président concernant la première
question concernant les référentiels et
les recommandations en ce qui concerne
l'ordre des chirurgiens dentistes je
dois dire que nous avons été à
l'initiation et à la réalisation de la
création de cette commission
scientifique en médecine bucco dentaire
dont l'ordre a effectué le pilotage et
aujourd'hui nous en sommes à la
troisième version de ces recommandations
qui est une version un petit peu plus
allégée mais l'ordre a été au pilotage
total de cette commission
et dieu sait s'il n'a pas été si c'était
compliqué le fait de réunir la totalité
la communauté scientifique c'était quand
monsieur le président que vous avez
débuté ce travail dès le tout début
au tout début des pros
concernant les d'antisant le pilotage et
la création de la commission
scientifique
oui et sa démission s'est exprimé à
partir de quand dès le début la deuxième
semaine du mois de mars entre le 20 et
le 30 mars vers le 20 et le 30 mars où
vous avez eu la version numéro 1 des
recommandations cette version a été
ensuite avalisé par la haute autorité de
santé mais qui est arrivé est évidemment
un tout dernier
donc vous ne regrettez pas d'avoir donné
la consigne de fermer les cabinets voilà
alors ça c'est le deuxième volet de la
question
non je ne regrette pas d'avoir donné la
recommandation de la fermeture des
cabinets pour évidemment une raison
essentielle c'est que nous nous sommes
aperçus depuis la mi-février dans les
échanges de courriers que nous avons
eues avec monsieur jérôme salomon que
visiblement l'état ne disposaient pas de
matériel de protection
à partir du moment notamment spécifique
pour les chirurgiens dentistes c'est à
dire les fêtes et 2 à partir du moment
où nous avons eu cette conviction il
était hors de question de laisser la
profession mes confrères mais conscient
chirurgiens dentistes exercer sa lettre
une véritable boucherie
donc j'ai pris et ce sera
vraisemblablement la seule fois puisque
je n'ai pas l'intention quoi qu'il
arrive de redemander à la profession la
fermeture des cabinets mais c'est
historique dans la profession jamais un
président d'ordre n'a demandé une
profession libérale de cesser son
activité
d'autant plus que j'avais demandé à
plusieurs reprises la couverture des
pouvoirs publics du ministre de la santé
et du premier ministre pour comment dire
appuyer cette recommandation que
j'avais instauré mais qui était à la
limite de la légalité qui ne s'appuyait
sur aucun fondement juridique
vraisemblablement les ffp2 plus les
surblouse de protection annoncé
mi-février que vous avez échangé avec le
directeur général de la santé pour de
bruit j'ai des échanges de mails
d'accord de notre mi février et fin
février l'accord dont vous pourrez nous
transmettre ces échanges rien entendu
merci monsieur le président merci merci
berlin avait posé bernard jaume i avait
posé la question à tous par oui ou par
non ce qui concerne les contacts avec la
dgs vous avez tous eu des contacts avec
la direction générale de la santé madame
au delà de cela nous avons été
sollicités par la haute autorité de
santé
je regardais la date le 25 mars pour
élaborer des réponses rapides qui vont
plus rapidement que les recommandations
qui met 6 à 9 mois et qui ont été
élaborée avec l'ordre et des personnes
que nous avons désigné de la profession
pour élaborer donc des réponses rapides
de la prise en charge des patients kovy
de plus et ensuite posco vide
nous avons eu aussi des relations
permanentes avec la haute autorité de
santé quand nous avons eu à faire
valider entre guillemets les
recommandations en matière d'hygiène et
d'accueil dans les cabinets que nous
avons instauré nous mêmes avec une
grande fluidité jeu là vous et
s'agissant des relations avec le cabinet
leigh à un conseiller qui que nous
sollicitions en tant que de besoin et
qui nous répondait toujours
instantanément même si ce qu'ils nous
répondent et ne nous satisfaisait pas
forcément en tout cas les réponses nous
les avions mais pas celle que nous
attendions toujours
jamais pour compléter les propos de m
prédécesseurs nous avons été convoqués à
la dgs à la demande de jérôme salon les
29 janvier et 6 février pour des
réunions de crise concernant le conseil
national de l'ordre des sages-femmes
n'avons pas été associés à la rédaction
du guide de préparation du 16 mars
nous l'avons regretté parce que nous
aurions pu anticiper l'organisation des
soins périnataux comme je lé déjà
précisés ont été maintenus et tout cas
notre consoeur qui n'hésitait à peu nous
avons aussi été associé aux travaux de
la haute autorité de santé
dans le cas des réponses rapides qui
sont intervenus en périnatalité un peu
plus tardivement ce qui se comprend on
regarde des priorités sanitaires au
cours du mois d'avril pour les
infirmiers avons été associés à la
réunion du 29 janvier 6 février puis des
réunions sous l'égide de la dgs qui
présentait les développement d'épidémies
nous avons pas été associés à quelques
démarches que ce soit nous nous avons
continué d'activité au fil de l'eau les
libéraux continuent à prendre en charge
emma professionnel très habitué à
prendre en charge des patients qui ont
une des bactéries multi résistantes ou
toutes autres pathologies transmissibles
est assez virulente donc on n'avait pas
mis de consignes particulières et pas de
cabinet ont fermé des mesures de
précaution ont été prises dans les
cabinets libéraux ils recevaient moins
de patients à chaque fois mais pas plus
de recommandations particulières ni de
fermeture ni d'arrêt des souhaits alors
non c'est toujours le même nombre ces
dix huit 18 masque habdomadaire avec
d'ainsi ffp2 ce qui était largement
insuffisant pour assurer la connectivité
et alors vous l'avez dit madame la
députée madame la sénatrice par delà la
question ne portait pas que sur les
fesses et 2 a porté aussi sur les sur
blues et quand thomas dans les domiciles
et comme suit 10 av nos missiles par
jour faire l'intro le matin et
l'après-midi les passages le feu de
l'été indispensable mais aussi d'autres
équipements
6 alors en ce qui concerne le jeu tirait
la collaboration des ordres de l'ordre
des pharmaciens avec les autorités donc
effectivement associé au démarrage aux
réunions qui ont eu lieu tant que les
réunions étaient possibles à la dgs je
crois qu'il y en ait encore jusqu'au 18
février me me semble-t-il
et puis après les choses ont été je
dirais plus au coup par coup en fonction
des choses qui se présentait je pense
notamment à la mise en place des
diverses mesures que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure où là on avait des contacts
essentiellement avec la dgs
effectivement des jeux confirme des
contacts avec le cabinet autant que de
besoin ou en tout cas une réactivité
certaine avec les cellules de crise
également notamment la cellule de crise
basque
pour la distribution des masques encore
une fois avec plus ou moins de succès ou
de réelle construction
voilà donc un peu je dirai au fil de
l'eau et au fil des événements et la
situation merci je ne serai pas
inutilement en redondance je confirme
effectivement les réunions auprès de la
dgs est en pointillé sent que c'est un
rythme systématique et régulier des
contacts il ya pu y avoir avec le
cabinet ministériel voire ponctuellement
avec le ministre merci le trine des
roches
merci monsieur le président bon j'avais
mon une première question mais bernard
je me la poser sur cette chronologique
et majeure entre dont vous nous annoncez
des réunions qu aurait lieu fin janvier
début février en fait des mesures après
qu'ont été prises alain pour certaines
27 mars alors que le gros de l'épidémie
dans grand test était début mars mais
est ce que lors de ses première réunion
a été évoquée la le stop de protection
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui a été
victime le deuxième point c'est vous
avez beaucoup parlé d'eux on a parlé
donc des relations avec la dgs et des
ministères mais comment se sont passées
les relations locales quelle était votre
interlocuteur privilégié est ce que
c'était le directeur de la rs régionales
où le directeur de la délégation
départementale comment vous avez
fonctionner bon on a parlé rupture de
soins mais comment se fait la reprise
c'est ça ça concerne vous l'avez évoqué
manama madame la présidente de l'ordre
des kinés mais comment se fait la
reprise également chez les dentistes où
on voit sur le terrain on al impression
lorsqu'on prend un rendez vous que les
délais sont très long parce que le
nombre de patients vus est très réduit
du fait des protections encore
nécessaire puisque le virus circule
question également comment se sont faits
les tout ce qui est lé dispositif de
télémédecine qui ont été assouplies
pendant cette période
est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez
voir pérennisées
et le dernier point est pour moi pour
l'ordre des médecins vous avez parlé de
sanctions disciplinaires et autres ce
qui a choqué beaucoup de praticiens
c'était quand même cette atteinte à la
liberté de prescription qui a été
cautionnée par le conseil de l'ordre
national
est-ce que vous pouvez répondre sur
cette question merci alors
principalement l'ordre des médecins oui
on va commencer par vous le vice
président madame le rapporteur la
liberté de prescription doit être
assortie d'un cadre qui est celui
habituellement de thérapeutique validé
et qui surtout ne met pas en danger la
vie d'autrui
tout en sachant que les patients ce
qu'on appelle communément les usagers de
la santé confie aux médecins en quelque
sorte le choix éclairé d'une
thérapeutique les patients n'ayant bien
évidemment pas la connaissance pour
faire le choix le tri entre tel ou tel
thérapeutique
cela est inscrit dans le code de santé
publique
et cela n'est nullement nouveau en
revanche effectivement ce qui l'est
c'est la situation inédite de cette
pandémie brutale et pour lequel nous
n'avions pas de thérapeutique est
prouvée pour autant cela n'est pas
suffisant à ce que les médecins
s'affranchissent de ces garanties de
sécurité qu'ils doivent apporter aux
patients
voilà donc en ce qui concerne les
sanctions disciplinaires
il n'y a pas de sanctions systématiques
sur des signalements on est dans un état
de droit
qui est écrit dans le code de santé
publique il y as au cas par cas des
auditions il peut y avoir ou non des
plaintes et en fonction des explications
qui seront apportées et de la gravité
potentielle des fautes qui ont été
commises
certains médecins pourront être traduits
en chambre disciplinaire de première
instance et ses champs disciplinaires
tout présidée par un magistrat elle
seule jugeront voilà donc on est dans un
état de droit avec une première instance
un niveau d' appel et un pourvoi en
conseil d'état
donc sa garantie ça nous a pas échappé
aux questions étaient précises la
prescription beaucoup de médecins et des
médecins qui ont prescrit et quand vous
interrogez individuellement des médecins
vous que vous dites moi j'aurai la
maladie je mangerai de la chloroquine
n'y a pas eu que la chloroquine non on
est dans une situation qui est complexe
comme je vous le dis la liberté d'écrire
que vous le temps scientifique est un
temps long
nous pour autant est-ce que parce que le
temps scientifique est plus long que de
juste attentes de nos concitoyens oui il
faut s'affranchir des règles de sécurité
vis-à-vis de la prescription du
médicament
certainement pas mais effectivement la
question que vous posez pour autant
demeure tout à fait licite
je crois qu'on peut pas s'exonérer de
règles qui garantissent fondamentalement
la sécurité du patient dans les
thérapeutiques qui leur sont proposés
non je fais pas je vais pas continuer le
débat sur ce sujet parce que je pense
que cela pourrait durer longtemps et je
pense qu'on arrivera jamais un accord
oui mais cette différence c'est le
sentiment de confiance aussi nos
concitoyens et il ya des choses qui
médicalement peut-être ne sont pas
entièrement justifiée mais qui s'y colle
logiquement dans une société sous
volontiers accepté sinon parce que je
voudrais pas que le débat soit pour ou
contre les drogues cyclos qui ne s'était
pas ça ma question parce qu'on a vu
circuler des des convocations si je puis
dire de confrères médecins parce qu'ils
aient prescrit des antibiotiques si
j'avais fait des associations
d'antibiotiques et autres qui ont été
quand même convoqué par le conseil
départemental de l'ordre pour qu'ils
s'expliquent sur cette prescription
reconnaissez que pour une profession
médicale toucher à cette liberté de
prescrire lorsqu'un médecin avoir
quelqu'un qui ne m'ont pas ti quelque
chose et pour lequel il essaie de faire
ce qu'il ya dans l'arsenal thérapeutique
ça peut poser des questions auprès des
collègues matin je crois qu'ils convient
d'être très précis convocation ne vaut
pas condamnation
ces explications le case de cas échéant
effectivement traduction devant une
chambre disciplinaire est dans un état
de droit
nous sommes très attachés à cet état de
droit tout médecin et ont fait l'objet
d'une plainte à toute possibilité bien
évidemment bien évidemment d'être
défendue de faire appel de cette
condamnation voire en phase ultime de
faire un pourvoi en cassation auprès du
conseil d'état
je crois que il y à aussi quantité de
confrères qui ne comprennent pas non
plus que la liberté d'expression de
prescription excusez moi c'est un lapsus
puis se sortir des règles qui jusqu'à
présent ont garanti la sécurité des
patients mais effectivement on est dans
une situation tout à fait inédite par la
brutalité de cette pandémie ou sur le
plan thérapeutique force est de
constater qu'on a été désarmé et qui
introduisent des réflexions
fondamentales qui doivent être davantage
portée et il n'y a absolument pas de
notre intention de fracturer temps la
communauté française que celle des
médecins d'édicter des principes qui
garantissent la sécurité auxquels nos
patients ont le droit le plus absolu
merci la deuxième question portait sur
la télémédecine ou le premier vous
souhaitez répondre
allez vous vous posez merci monsieur le
président vous aviez posé une question
sur la reprise et je voudrais insister
justement sur la perte de chance selon
moi je n'ai pas de chiffres évidemment
qui qui est une évidence faute de
kinésithérapeute dans les établissements
de santé y compris dans les services de
soins et de réadaptation ssr très
souvent il n'ya pas de kinésithérapeutes
et donc on confie des patients à
d'autres professionnels en imaginant que
c'est la rééducation
faute de kinésithérapeute dans beaucoup
d'établissements de santé on recrute des
éducateurs sportifs par exemple diplômé
de la fac de sport ce qui est tout à
fait intéressant ils ont un rôle à jouer
dans le système de santé
mais ma grosse crainte actuellement
c'est que sous couvert de sport santé
faute de kinésithérapeute au lieu de
prendre les choses en main c'est à dire
de les payer convenablement et de les
recruter dans les établissements on met
des succédanés qui ne sont pas des
rééducateurs qui ne sont pas des
professionnels de santé qui pour
certains en licence
trois ans de formation au sport
passionnant certainement ça je n'ai
aucun doute là dessus
et puis parfois qu'ils font 30 heures
dédié à la médecine et ça s'appelle
sport santé et de ce fait dans des
établissements on leur confie des
passions en lieu et place des
kinésithérapeutes et ça pour moi c'est
un véritable scandale sanitaire
et quand je parle de perte de chance
elle ne se mesure pas parce que vous
avez les neuro myopathies consécutive à
la réanimation qui implique des lésions
musculaires qui implique des lésions
articulaires je ne vais pas rentrer dans
un tableau clinique très très large mais
qui ont été parfaitement décrit
notamment par des médecins de
rééducation il ya eu des travaux faits
dans le cadre du coc vide et qui
demandait rééducation très spécifique
est particulière et ces patients là
s'ils ont une capacité de récupération à
80% par exemple mais qui ne récupère que
de 60% qui va le dire est qu'ils veulent
savoir c'est sa réelle perte de chance
et donc là je pense que c'est un moyen
aussi de dire il faut que ce système
change notamment parce que beaucoup de
kinésithérapeute s'était inscrit sur les
plateformes renfort qu'ovide et bien à
un moment j'ai été obligé d'arrêter j'ai
tous les mails le recrutement d'un
ostéopathe en réanimation en région
parisienne alors que des
kinésithérapeutes étaient inscrits et
dans la réserve sanitaire et sur la
plateforme renfort qu'ovide est comme ça
s'est ébruitée sur les réseaux sociaux
via twitter nicolas péju le directeur
adjoint de la rs ile de france m'a
appelé et m'a dit mais qu'est ce qui se
passe
et finalement il m'a dit ben oui l'ap-hp
n'est pas au courant plus sur la
plateforme renfort qu'ovide il y a des
kinésithérapeutes
ils savent qui est des médecins et qu'il
y à des infirmiers mais personne n'ya
pensé voyez on est à des
dysfonctionnements de cet ordre là
donc voilà ce que je voulais vous dire
pour la télémédecine ça a été pour nous
un véritable scandale
tout simplement parce que j'ai écrit au
ministre dès le début du confinement
pour lui demander le thé les soins qui
était absolument fondamental pour nous
et ça permettait de maintenir des soins
de rééducation à distance tout en
préservant la santé de nos concitoyens
et des kinésithérapeutes qui n'avaient
pas d'équipement
on a vu passer les textes pour les
orthophonistes ce qui me semblait
important et intéressant pour les
ergothérapeutes pour les
psychomotriciens et nous on n'arrivait
jamais il a fallu encore une fois que
j'interpelle nicolas revel via twitter
pour dire que comment ça se fait qu'on
était les paillassons pourquoi on était
les paillassons parce que ce qui
bloquait c'est que pour les
kinésithérapeutes
on voulait donner un acte dégradée c'est
à dire inférieur au tarif habituel alors
que ni pour les sages femmes ni pour les
infirmiers mais pour les médecins ce qui
était tout à fait normal d'ailleurs la
cght n'avait été abaissé et on m'a dit
mais c'est pour la traçabilité est en
fait j'ai dit d'accord
du coup augmenter le un petit peu mais
t1 à mk 1.1 en plus haut lieu de le
mettre inférieur donc quand j'ai un
petit peu réagi de façon très vigoureuse
je gérais là ça s'est débloqué en deux
jours mais nous n'avons eu les textes
que le 16 avril alors que nous avions
demandé cela dès le début du confinement
que j'ai écrit à bruno le maire que j'ai
écrit à cédric haut que j'ai écrit
olivier vers ans que je viens j'ai écrit
partout et j'avais l'impression de ne
pas être entendus c'est à dire ah oui
alors non non non non parce qu'on a on a
maintenu l'activité
oui ils ont eu l'aide de 1500 euros et
nous avons été aidés bien sûr même si ça
ne couvrait pas tout et qu'il y avait
les soins à domicile quand même mais les
soins à domicile
oui les soins à domicile aussi pourquoi
beaucoup de kinésithérapeutes ne font
plus de domicile
alors c'est quelque chose que j'ai mis à
l'ordre du jour du prochain conseil
national dans 15 jours parce que je suis
sollicité à outrance par des patients
qui ne trouvent plus de kiné pour aller
à domicile mais parce qu'aussi une
question de tarif et que c'est du
travail à perte alors je ne suis pas là
pour parler des rémunérations c'est pas
mon sujet est encore mais la qualité des
soins et des passions c'est quand même
une préoccupation pour moi et
contraindre les kinésithérapeutes aller
à domicile moi je n'en ai pas les moyens
mais ceci dit pour 2 euros
c'est compliqué
oui merci monsieur le président
évidemment concernant la
téléconsultation je vais aller un tout
petit peu plus loin que mon homologue
que des masseurs kinésithérapeutes parce
que nous l'arrêté nous l'attendons
toujours
donc ce n'est pas faute d'avoir fait
évidemment le siège de l'ensemble des
instances et je dois dire que si au
moins une télé consultation
comment dire provisoire dans le temps au
moins durant la crise avait été mis en
place je pense qu'en termes de santé
publique
une quantité de patients auraient pu
être soignées également et en nombre un
nombre conséquent parce qu'évidemment
chirurgie dentaire il ya les actes
techniques mais il ya aussi l'acte
intellectuelle qui va avec et un certain
nombre de corps aurait pu être temporisé
par par ces téléconsultations en ce qui
concerne le déconfinement puisqu'il y
avait une question sur ce sujet je peux
dire que le déconfinement ce qui
concerne les chirurgiens dentistes a été
réussi mais cette fois ci il a été
réussi grâce à l'état puisque le
ministère nous a fourni 150 mille
masques cash que nous avons distribué
par l'intermédiaire des conseils de
l'ordre je parle un masque ffp2 mais
également les dotations d'état
et là je voudrais évidemment remercier
nos amis ce pharmacien qui ont une fois
de plus accepté de participer à la
distribution hebdomadaire qui a bien
rendu service aux chirurgiens dentistes
et qui leur a permis de redémarrer leurs
activités
ceci dit et maintenant l'activité nous
sommes assez inquiet de par les
investissements importants qui existent
dans les cabinets dentaires et le nombre
de patients
journalier que nous pouvons voir c'est à
dire un par heure malgré des
recommandations allégé qui vont pas
manquer d'entraîner un moyen terme des
problèmes des problèmes économiques et
évidemment des problèmes de santé
publique puisque on voit des patients
qui cherche en fait à être reçus dans un
cabinet dentaire ce qui évidemment pose
un gros problème déontologique et
éthique de la santé merci pour les
sages-femmes vient poursuivre merci
beaucoup
vous aviez posé le cosim questions
concernant les relations avec les ars
cette relation avec les ars a sans doute
été moins marquée au niveau national
puisque les échanges se faisait au
niveau national avec les autorités de
santé nationales pour l'ordre national
mais nous avons interrogé nos collègues
élus départementale et régionale et nous
avons aussi interroger l'ensemble de la
communauté sage femme concernant les
relations établies
nous avons noté des variabilités c'est
variabilité aller de l'association des
sages femmes alors de surcroît quand une
sage femme exerce dans une ars
l'habitude veut qu'on oublie moi la
santé périnatale est la place des sages
femmes
donc cela allait à une sociation avec
une présence des sages femmes pour
discuter notamment des liens ville
hôpitaux et a contrario nous avons des
ars qui ont complètement omis de convier
les sages femmes lors d'une information
professionnels de santé sur les risques
liés au virus
si dans le cadre de la deûle enquêtes
que nous avons menées auprès des 24
mille sage femme quasi 11000 sages
femmes ont répondu à cette enquête ce
qui montre la proactivité de la
profession dans cette dans cette
pandémie
sur les onze mille répondantes nous
avons 42 % et sa femme qui ont annoncé
avoir des relations avec leurs ars ce
qui signifie quand même que nous en
laissons 58% sur le côté concernant la
télémédecine là nous pouvons remercier
le ministère d'avoir apporté une réponse
rapide
l'ordre national a saisi le ministère le
14 mars pour demander le remboursement
des actes de télémédecine qui a été acté
cinq jours plus tard donc là nous avons
une véritable réactivité cependant je
pondère mes propos en disant que cela
est soumis à échéance à ce jour le
remboursement des actes de télémédecine
les sages-femmes va s'éteindre le 31
octobre la profession est très en
attente d'une pérennisation de ce
dispositif
concernant le déconfinement vous l'avez
compris dans mes propos liminaire les
achats menées n'ont pas interrompu leur
activité elles ont bien évidemment de
réserver au moment du des confirmands
moi aussi je suis je tiens à remercier
mes collègues pharmaciens pour leur
réactivité
vous avez vu que nous avons été très
modulée par les notes de la dgse
concernant la dotation de masques cela a
demandé aux professionnels de l'officine
de s'adapter de façon extrêmement rapide
aux demandes des sages-femmes qui
veillait jours et demi aux publications
de la dgf merci
les relations avec les ars à fait moi je
l'aurais ainsi remis à la vidéo le
cabinet santé avec un conseiller
particulier effectivement par sms ou par
téléphone les réponses qui nous
satisfaisait pas régulièrement mais on
avait des relations sociales avec les
ars
moi je me suis toujours posé la question
mais pourquoi il y avait des conférences
régionales de santé d'autonomie ou bien
que les médecins ne le voit c'est une
question on est les seuls professionnels
de santé à travers une carte répartis
sur le territoire
et on n'est pas présent dans les airs et
ça ne coûte agnant que les infirmiers ne
sommes pas comme une vie en général
c'est à ces conférences là et à ces
informations la donne en sait quelque
chose quand même que je voudrais voir
évoluer très largement concernant le
télé souhait on a eu un texte assez
rapidement mais soumis à une
déclenchement par une prescription
médicale
alors qu'ils avaient pas d alors qu'ils
avaient pas d'équipements de protection
individuelle disponibles alors c'était
quand même une façon d'avoir une
présence d'un professionnel de santé
puisque dans le même temps on a vu les
consultations médicales fortement évolué
en télémédecine et les maisons firmi
quasiment être il ya les professionnels
de santé à se rendre aux dossiers des
patients qui en a besoin d'équipements
progression pouvait être une protection
d'autant plus que l'on a été saisi et
qu'on a mis neuf ans aux questions en
ligne sur notre site internet ou les
infirmiers nous signaler que des
patients alors refuser l'accès au
domicile il ya eu des abandons de soins
parce qu'ils les patients par ainsi que
les infirmiers étaient des vecteurs
potentiels de la pathologie de que c'est
assez compliqué de ne pas pouvoir faire
de télé souhait parce qu'il faut que les
médecins qui fasse une prescription
médicale pour pouvoir déclencher télé
souhait y'a pas d'autonomie sur le
profit pour l'infirmier de déclencher le
téléthon et nous que ça aussi quelque
chose au-delà de la norme pérennité à ce
jour du texte sur le télésiège de ses
modalités de rédaction qui sommes pas le
même que pour les kinés notamment
puisque les kinés des clarks noter les
souhaits sur leurs compétences propres
je pense que les iem fermiers font
autant d'études que les kinés et pour
avoir cette liberté là pour les
infirmités soumet la prescription mais
cal donc concernant les relations raison
plutôt été avec les représentants de
proximité de la république les maires et
les dts ou là vraiment il ya eu des
facilités de discussion pour l'ordre
même voulu sortir ajouté oui quel
quelques propos effectivement sur la
pénurie effectivement de matériel de
protection donc à votre question ou une
audition souvent notamment lors de la
dernière réunion à la dgs le 18 février
pardon est-ce que c'est mieux comme ça
peut-être mais pardon donc oui on savait
qu'il y avait une difficulté notamment
sur l'acheminement des masques du stock
et à qui se situait donc santé publique
france vers les professionnels de santé
notamment ceux de premier recours et
c'est à cette réunion du 18 février que
j'ai proposé
que d'utiliser le réseau des pharmaciens
pour justement faire cette distribution
aux professionnels locaux puisque de par
leur maillage d'une part et leur
présence sur tout le territoire et
surtout ouvert en cette période est
accessible puisque tous les autres lieux
étaient évidemment fermé c'était une
solution et par le maillage mais aussi
par le système de distribution en gros
donc à la fois les dépositaires et les
grossistes répartiteurs qui était du
coup en capacité sur la partie
logistique d'aller chercher ces masques
chez santé publique france et de les
acheminer en toute sécurité dans les
officines donc oui nous étions au
courant
la seule chose qu'on ne savait pas trop
et qu'on a jamais trop su c'est qu'elle
était réellement le stock disponible
et combien nous allions pouvoir
distribuer aux professionnels de santé
dans les premières semaines et ensuite
évidemment de du confinement votre
interlocuteur c'était santé publique
france où les erreurs alors non c'était
pas du tout les ars ça a été soit la
cellule de crise masque même et là
c'était plus les ordres déjà c'était
vraiment les opérationnels j'allais dire
directement les dépositaires et les
grossistes répartiteurs pour la partie
vraiment logistique et nous n'étions pas
en tant qu'ordre du tout dans les
discussions de notamment de la
discussion des dotations bien évidemment
vous voyez juste arrivé dans le dg sur
jean ba voila vous allez donner 18 au
médecin douze 6 voilà on n'était pas à
ce moment là du tout évidemment ni même
c'est nous qui portons les masques
c'était vraiment voilà le concernant la
relation justement avec les ars je
dirais la même chose que que mes
collègues en fait c'était très régional
dépendants j'allais dire d'abord en
fonction de la crise dans la région
évidemment les relations par exemple je
dirais dans le grand test était tout à
fait différente de la normandie par
exemple où j'exerce où il y avait voilà
donc donc évidemment c'était très
fluctuant en fonction de la situation
sanitaire dans la dans la région et puis
effectivement des interloqué
thor c'était souvent les yeux rps qui
sont aussi les interlocuteurs j'allais
dire privilégier des drs mais localement
bien évidemment il ya eu des contacts et
des organisations sur la télémédecine si
vous permettait même si les pharmaciens
sont peut-être moins directement
concernés encore que sur le thé les
soins également
je voudrais juste profité de cette
tribune pour dire qu'on appelle de nos
voeux depuis très longtemps l'aï
prescription puisque une fois qu la
téléconsultation est passé il ya donc
une prescription et vous savez qu'on a
et on a énormément de fraude et de
fausse ordonnance liées justement aux
ordonnances dématérialisée parce qu'il
n'y a rien de plus difficile pour nous
au comptoir d'avoir une ordonnance sur
un smartphone et de dire elle est bonne
elle est fausse elle a déjà été délivré
dans une autre pharmacie ou pas donc ça
a été une vraie difficulté pour nous
c'est de tenter d'authentifier autant
que faire se peut la validité de la de
la prescription et surtout ne pas éviter
que ce soit cette prescription soit
alors évidemment c'est pour ça que la
solution
ah ça c'est vraiment l'aï prescription
qui est en travaux bien sûr mais depuis
bien longtemps et qu'on appelle de
nouveau depuis depuis longtemps on est
très en retard je crois en france sur
ceux sur ce sujet je sens en ranimé le
débat sur la liberté de prescription
je voulais juste dire que en tant que
pharmacien au comptoir
ce qui est important pour nous quand il
ya effectivement une prescription aura
et même très clairement c'est que ce
soit indiqué sur la prescription et
souvent ça n'est pas le cas et je pense
que ce qui est important ce sens du tout
remettre en cause la liberté de
prescription c'est que je pense qu'il
faut que chacun
du coup sache que le médecin l'indiquent
sur l'ordonnancé explique aux patients
et que le pharmacien lui même quand il
délivre il puisse réellement éclairé du
coup le patient dire voilà vous avez un
produit
le médecin a dû vous expliquer voilà
c'est ces ora et mep
du coup ça n'est pas remboursée par
ailleurs accessoirement c'est mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que c'est pas
pour autant pour remettre en cause la
liberté passion mais elle doit être fait
dans un cadre réglementaire aura mêmes
et d'ailleurs je tiens par ailleurs à
vous informer que conjointement l'ordre
des médecins est l'ordre des pharmaciens
nous allons publier dans les jours qui
viennent un guide justement sur la
prescription et la délivrance aura mêmes
que faut-il faire quelles sont les
responsabilités engagées
oui monsieur le président très
brièvement pour terminer c'est
effectivement ce sujet sur la liberté
d'expression
les règles et la loi disent qu'il faut
prescrire selon les règles
d'autorisation de mise sur le marché
l'europe aurait même oblige le
prescripteur à donner toute
l'information
en dix ans les raisons pour lesquelles
il passe hors de la mm et foot il
rappelé des dommages sérielle
considérable vis-à-vis de prescription
de médicaments aura et même avec des
victimes et des associations de victimes
qui vraiment aurait du mal à entendre
qu'on puisse prescrire sent
effectivement ces contraintes là parce
qu'elles en ont payé parfois de leur vie
ou dans leur famille pour les agences
régionales je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec ce qui a été dit c'est très
dépendant d'une région à l'autre
certaines agences régionales de santé
l'île de france la nouvelle à qui tu es
mais d'autres ont su nouer des relations
particulièrement bienveillante et de
qualité avec les professionnels et les
ordres non seulement les conseils
départementaux mais aussi en relais les
conseils régionaux en ce qui nous
concerne
enfin la télémédecine on peut dire que
rien ne sera comme avant
mais qu'est-ce qu'il faut il faut
séparer l'ivraie du bon grain qu'est ce
qu'il faudra retenir de la télémédecine
c'est tout le chantier il faudra veiller
à ce que l'essor de la télémédecine ne
se fasse pas sans perte de qualité des
soins et il faudra
ayez aussi on l'a pu le voir notamment
l'école et les téléconsultations
qu'ovide le problème de la fracture
sociale numérique territoriale et la
télémédecine peut pas résoudre cela il
ya vraiment des barrages à l'accès aux
soins
selon certaines catégories sociales
tranches d'âge territoire des certes
numérique et il faut veiller à ce que
l'accès aux soins y ait une équité dans
l'accès aux soins pour tous passé
aux questions des commissaires j'ai
trois quatre cinq six sept huit
inscriptions
nous allons prendre vos questions quatre
par quatre si vous en êtes d'accord
muriel jourda
merci monsieur le président j'ai trois
questions la première et pour monsieur
le vice président de l'ordre des du
conseil de l'ordre des médecins
vous avez indiqué tout à l'heure qu'il y
avait de nombreux rapports sur
l'accroissement des zoonoses depuis
quelques dizaines d'années
pouvez vous nous dire dans la mesure de
vos connaissances 1 qui établit ses
rapports et de quelle façon ils ont pu
être transcrit et transmis aux pouvoirs
publics
ma deuxième question s'adresse à qui
voudra bien y répondre
parce que je pense que tout le monde est
concerné vous avez tous indiqué avoir eu
des réunions avec le ministère notamment
la direction générale de la santé ou des
pénuries de deux pays avait été acté
quoique les chiffres n'en soit pas
connue si j'ai bien compris
à un moment ou un autre at-il été évoqué
la possibilité d'un confinement général
comme une réponse à ce manque à cette
pénurie de pays
et enfin la troisième question est
quelque peu différente elle est adressée
à madame la présidente du conseil de
l'ordre des pharmaciens
vous avez indiqué quelle a été votre
rôle dans le recueil des propos des pas
des plaintes des propos des femmes pour
les violences conjugales la pharmacie
s'est elle révélée un lieu approprié
autrement dit avez vous pu effectivement
exercer ce rôle et quelle a été
l'importance des propos des femmes que
vous avez pu recueillir
merci victoire jasmin oui merci beaucoup
monsieur le président je vous remercie
tous pour différentes interventions
alors avant de poser une question
voudrais dire au président de l'ordre
des infirmiers que dans les conférences
régionales de santé de l'autonomie il
n'y a pas que les médecins j'ai chaque
organisation qui proposent ces candidats
dont qui allie représentants d'élus des
différents élus mais aussi les yeux aps
les métiers mais ce sont les
organisations qui font les propositions
boksic vous êtes intéressé ou les
personnes de votre organisation
il suffit qu avec lui au ps ou avec vos
syndicats respectifs
voici la demande donc voilà concernant
les sages-femmes je voudrais demander à
la représentante de la de l'ordre des
sages-femmes qui est de son avis sur les
maisons de naissance et en pareille
circonstance est-ce que les maisons de
naissance aurait pour reporter une
plus-value je dirais en complémentarité
avec les structures conventionnelles
l'autre chose c'est à mon avis également
pendant cette période il ya eu des
freins pour diverses raisons
vers les effets de notre structure est
particulièrement vers des professionnels
de santé
des fois qu'ils étaient liés à
l'obligation de justifier les
déplacements parce que beaucoup de
personnes étaient contraintes des cuirs
pour dire où ils allaient et à les
personnes qui avaient des rendez-vous et
à des professionnels qui étaient
disponibles seulement ces personnes
n'avaient pas forcément la capacité
d'écrire ou alors mon colt france et est
dématérialisé mais il ya des personnes
qui n'avaient pas accès et sa lettre
d'être dit par le représentant de
l'ordre des médecins et à des personnes
qui n'ont pas accès au numérique
donc il ne savait même pas qu'il fallait
ve quelquefois télécharger un document
prédéfinis et il ya les personnes qui
sont victimes de l'illettrisme tout
simplement
donc là aussi je crois que ce n'était
pas l'un des meilleurs moyens pour
permettre aux personnes de justifier de
leur déplacement donc les gens qui
avaient des besoins de swing quel qu'il
soit n'était pas forcément favorisés par
ces différentes dispositions
je dirais également qu'il y avait à mon
avis également une hiérarchisation des
différents professionnels et
particulièrement de certains
paramédicaux parce que les autres pistes
les autos faunistique un certain nombre
de professionnels qui ont à mon avis une
utilité et qui ont été écartés les
dispositions qui avaient été prises et
ça les ai beaucoup de personnes
également des familles de peuvent soit
des adultes mais aussi des enfants qui
avaient des soins et quelquefois ça a
été difficile dans cette période-là pour
ces personnes
l'autre chose que que je dirais
également c'est concernant conscient oui
concernant les différentes organisations
alors les professionnels par exemple tel
que les infirmières de pratiques
avancées
alors est-ce que à ce moment là dans les
moments difficiles et compliquées comme
nous l'avons connue est ce que c'est
bien seul avait suffisamment été pris en
compte sur leur territoire compte tenu
des différentes dispositions qui avaient
été prises et principalement focalisée
sur tout hospitalier pendant une période
en négligeant évidemment les
professionnels libéraux qui étaient
disponibles et qui attend des événements
qu'il y ait des prises en compte de
l'identifier que l'outil
particulièrement pour leur dotation et
quelquefois c'était compliqué difficile
en fonction de l'aménagement du
territoire voilà je vais avec là je vous
remercie
merci annie guillemot
oui merci monsieur le président moi je
voudrais intervenir sur deux points
essentiels notamment sur on a peut-être
pas bien entendu mais en tout cas sur
les difficultés pendant le confinement
sur le terrain au niveau de l'ensemble
des professions je parle je pense par
exemple aux pharmaciens moi j'ai quand
même souvenir de pharmaciens qui se
faisait vraiment entre guillemets
engueuler toute la journée pour avoir
des masques
j'en ai vu pleurer et quand il s'est agi
de les distribuer à certaines
professions de santé et bien toutes les
aides à domicile tous les ehpad oulémas
pas ne l'avait pas mais je pense aussi
aux dentistes qui était fermé je pense
que la reprise se prend se fait
difficilement
moi même j'ai voulu prendre rendez vous
début juin j'ai pas de rendez vous avant
octobre
donc c'est quand même un problème aussi
de santé
je pense aux sages femmes alors c'est
vrai que j'ai été longtemps maire de bon
mais il ya tous les hôpitaux chez moi
neuro cardio hôpital mère enfant etc
mais enfin les sages femmes avaient des
sacs poubelles elle ne savait même pas
si celle qu'elle a couché avec au vide
donc moi j'y tiens c'est vrai que je
suis une élue d'une ville où il ya
énormément de pitot mais tout de même
c'est quand même quelque chose j'ai pas
ressenti les difficultés auxquelles vous
enfin en tout cas le citoyen à vue et
c'est vrai que le citoyen par exemple
pour les prescriptions la non
prescription diderot claude thin
comprennent pas enfin moi j'ai envie de
vous dire à quoi servent les ordres si
on convoque les médecins qui ne peuvent
pas prescrire ou en tout cas quand nous
prescrits et la cacophonie qu'on
entendait sur toutes les chaînes avec
des médecins qui disait tout à l'heure
contraire et l'ordre on savait pas où il
était on entend et je vous le dis à tous
moi j'ai jamais entendu les ordres
vraiment s'exprimer sur cette situation
là et c'est vrai qu'il dit plein
10/10/10 publicité mais c'est vrai que
la cacophonie aujourd'hui explique aussi
ou peut-être pourquoi il ya une défiance
vis-à-vis des consignes pour les
citoyens mais moi j'aimerais que l'on
revienne un peu un peu là dessus parce
que c'est vrai que sur tous les services
d aide à domicile infirmiers et
kinésithérapeutes sont extrêmement une
offre un indispensable et on a bien vu
et vous avez parlé de perte de chance et
je pense que ce que c'est vrai donc sur
ce premier point c'est vrai que enfin en
tout cas je pense qu'on avait tué
beaucoup de gens ont vécu les très
grandes difficultés et que je n'ai pas
ressenti aujourd'hui le deuxième point
ça s'adresse plus bien au kiné au
kinésithérapeute
vous avez parlé de paillasson pour avoir
travaillé beaucoup sur cette question
être intervenu souvent en question et et
écrites ou orales
je pense qu'il ya vraiment un problème
de reconnaissance vous n'avez pas obtenu
la revalorisation tarifaire
le congé maternité non plus alors que
les femmes médecins l'ont eu
inclusion des études dans le cursus
universitaire alors vous êtes obligé
aujourd'hui d'avoir le concours de
médecine comme les autres et là vous
dites paillasson et moi en vous
entendant c'est vrai que je suis un peu
inquiète de voir qu'aujourd'hui on
recommence dans certains ehpad a pas
vouloir avoir décliné
c'est comme pour les infirmiers
aujourd'hui nous avons eu des gens à
domicile j'ai été maire pendant 17 ans
donc les gens m'appelaient bien sûr
aujourd'hui sénatrice qui n'ont pas vu
un kiné pendant quatre mois cinq mois et
qui aujourd'hui alors qu'il marchait ne
marche plus mais dans cette société là
où en plus quand on va à l'hôpital on
met tout de suite les jambes à domicile
et on le favorise tant mieux sauf que
s'il n'y a pas derrière d'affirmer de
kiné et quand on est mais on nous
demande infirmiers kinés et on vient
pleurer dans cas dans le bureau du maire
pour en trouver
maintenant il ya même les médecins les
infirmiers je crois que ça va un peu
mieux mais les kinés et je ne comprends
pas comment aujourd'hui kiné n'arrivez
pas à vous faire re connaître et vous
avez dit paillasson ça a attiré mon
attention moi sur les kinés j'ai eu
beaucoup de demandes consignes
contraires beaucoup de consignes
contraires on leur a dit de laisser leur
cabinet ouvert ensuite de les fermer
ensuite de les rouvrir ensuite de les
faire mais bon j'aimerais que vous nous
disiez un peu comment ça s'est passé
le forfait sur coup
moi je suis étonné de voir les kinés
mais je pense que pour les dentistes
c'est pareil vous disiez tout à l'heure
il ya des consignes un protocole
extrêmement lourd on met toutes ses
affaires dans un sac
ensuite il faut tout désinfecter etc
sauf que quand on va sur la plage ou une
page privée personne ne désinfecte rien
et donc ce forfait sur coup quand est-ce
que lectines et vont en parler et vous
peut-être avoir une compensation on le
voit toujours pas venir et je voudrais
aussi insisté sur le manque de produits
aujourd'hui auxquels sont confrontés un
certain nombre de vos pairs parce qu'ils
n'arrivent plus à trouver des produits
désinfectants qui respectent les normes
c'est un grave problème pour les kinés
mais je pense pour un certain nombre
d'autres et on n'en a pas parlé
aujourd'hui voilà c'est les deux points
principaux sur lesquels je voulais
intervenir
si je suis nagui days oui merci
président merci mesdames et messieurs
pour votre différentes interventions
ma question ira au président du conseil
de l'ordre des médecins
j'ai aussi médecin de mon territoire ils
n'ont pas compris la communication entre
cas du gouvernement dans le sens où ils
ont demandé à la patientèle de rester
chez eux par rapport aux dangers du coc
vide de ne pas se déplacer dans le
cabinet ce qui a été en effet très bien
suivi résultat les médecins n'ont pas vu
leur patientèle
alors que certains avaient des suivis
réguliers pour des pathologies bien
spécifique et très grave
certains sont même décidé non pas du
couvent il met dehors pas propre
pathologie donc ma question c'est serré
une deuxième vague est ce que vous
pensez réagir de la même façon
merci on commence pas vous monsieur oui
monsieur président si vous voulez bien
j'ai identifié quatre sujets tout
d'abord effectivement les zones hausse
et le risque sanitaire a crû de pandémie
donc je ne m'attendais pas tout à fait à
cette question donc j'ai pas les
références j'ai pas l'habitude de faire
la publicité des réseaux sociaux
ceci étant dit soit vous me donnez votre
adresse mail et je vous communiquerai
avec plaisir ces rapports soient jeu
vous permet à ce moment-là d'arrêt sur
mon compte twitter personnel ayant des
tweets que j'ai pu envoyer il ya
quelques semaines où vous avez notamment
les références de d'un de ses rapports
qu'est ce que disent ces rapports c'est
que l'augmentation des zones aux est
réelle depuis plusieurs décennies
lle très brièvement à multiples critères
le réchauffement climatique la perte de
la biodiversité l'urbanisation les
modifications des modes de pratiques
agricoles et caetera et on pourrait
parler de risques sanitaires au pluriel
puisque dans le même temps il va falloir
que dans une véritable politique de
prévention de santé publique nous
absorbons les défis liés au
réchauffement climatique canicule de
2003 faut pas l'oublier
les maladies vectorielles je suis moi en
exercice dans le sud-ouest et maintenant
nous avons des moustiques quasiment
toute l'année avec des cas autochtone de
dengue est bien évidemment d'autres
sujets tels que les perturbateurs
endocriniens les insecticides etc
donc il ya vraiment une réflexion
fondamentale à ce que ses priorités de
politique de santé publique et de
prévention soit vraiment une des
priorités sinon opéra au centuple
l'insuffisance de port de ces politiques
là alors il y en a quatre ou cinq j'ai
entendu parler du confinement je crois
que de toute façon dans tous les pays le
confinement s'est imposée et là où le
confinement ne s'est pas fait ou a été
lite on dira notamment dans des régimes
populiste la population et la se payer
un lourd tribut avec une mortalité
particulièrement fortes notamment outre
atlantique
excusez moi monsieur le vice président
mais la question est de miches de muriel
jourda n'était pas tout à fait si vous
pouvez peut-être reformuler votre
question parce qu'elle est déjà assez
ancien d'abord sur le sur les halles
rapport relatif aux zones aux ma
question était comment sont-ils transmis
aux pouvoirs publics à votre
connaissance si vous le savez c'est pas
je suis désolé je serai bien c'était
j'avais indiqués dans la maison de
connaissances et la question sur le
confinement était de savoir si dans vos
rapports qui ont été réguliers en fin
janvier février d'après ce que vous avez
tous syndiqués avec le ministère et la
direction générale de la santé
le confinement général a été évoqué
comme pouvant être une solution en
raison de la pénurie d'équipements de
protection bouder c'est pas un secret en
janvier autant que je sache non avant
début mars
oui puisqu'il circulaient des rumeurs
qu'il y aurait un confinement pour
certaines régions les plus atteintes
et puis s'est invitée au débat politique
mais je ne rentrerai pas dans ce débat
effectivement des rendez vous électoraux
voilà vont après moi il m'appartient pas
de savoir s'il était pertinent ou non
non le confinement
on savait qu'il y aurait un confinement
très probable disons début mars je crois
que c'est évident enfin ma voisine va
s'exprimer autant que je sache
en janvier février le confinement
généralisée n'était pas prononcée en
tant que je sache
bah écoutez dans les rapports que nous
avions
ça ne m'était pas stipulé
autant que je sache mais dès début mars
oui oui ça c'est ça a été clairement
édictées la question était de savoir ça
semblait hélas dans la mesure où on
avait plus de méprise sur ces fameux
kloster la question était de savoir
quand ce confinement aurait lieu voilà
c'était davantage ce cela en ce qui
concerne la la cacophonie dans
l'expression médiatique ça je ne peux
que effectivement vous donner raison
dans la cacophonie
je m'exprimerai cette fois ci en tant
que médecin généraliste en exercice dans
le lot-et-garonne tous les jours
j'entends des patients le déplorer donc
je vais dire je suis extrêmement
sensibilisé à cela je crois qu'il ya
deux questions fondamentales qui se
posent
lorsqu'on est une expression il faudra
que nous aussi on le rappelle à
l'ensemble des médecins il ya un travail
qui est en cours dessus c'est à ton
légitimité à s'exprimer
on peut pas être experts de tous si on
connaît pas le sujet et deuxièmement
avant de s'exprimer
à t-on au préalable fait une expertise
vraiment attendre pleine connaissance du
sujet à débattre pour que l'expression
soit robuste et effectivement
manifestement c'est pas le cas je ne
parlerai pas parfois effectivement
d'expression opposés pour des conflits
mais
je crois qu'il faudra remettre de
l'ordre dans tout cela
reconnaissez cependant que la situation
était tout à fait inédite en ce qui
concerne le fait que des patients
étaient invités à rester chez eux
il y a notamment une expression sans
aucune intentionnalité malveillantes je
veux pas le dire mais du premier
ministre qui a dit en quelque sorte
d'aller dans les cabinets médicaux que
s'il était convoqué convoqué c'est tout
à fait un terme qui était pas approprié
est absolument inhabituel
et effectivement les patients sont pas
venus soit ils avaient peur d'être
infectés dans les cabinets de soins soit
ils prenaient ça comme effectivement une
injonction à surtout ne pas se déplacer
soit il y avait certes un parcours de
soins qui était chaotique avec des
annulations de rendez-vous tout ça pèle
mêle fait qu'effectivement il y a eu des
parcours qui ont tardé avec des pertes
de chance alors on peut simplement
espérer là je crois que les différents
acteurs auront un rôle majeur
si on revenait non pas dans un
confinement généralisée qui semble
excessivement peu probable mais dans une
tension forte du système de santé avec
des mesures assez stricts selon les
territoires
je crois qu'effectivement il faudra qu
avec les acteurs locaux
là pour le coup les agences régionales
de santé mais pas qu'eux au niveau des
bassins de vie des départements il y ait
véritablement des réunions pour savoir
en pratique comment on évite les
ruptures de soins trop nombreux ceux qui
aiment et enfin dernier sujet c'est les
ehpad et là je viendrai en appui de
pascal mathieu le problème des pâtes
c'est un problème en dehors même de la
pandémie qu'ovide voilà des
établissements où même les médecins
traitants au fil du temps ne vont moins
parce qu'il y a des difficultés d'accès
aux soins de coordination de soins
et on peut espérer qu'il y ait un
véritable efforts déployés en faveur des
ehpad dans les mesures qui suivront le
ségur ça reste peut-être un voeu pieux
mais sincèrement les médecins
coordonnateurs mise en place d'abord il
ya des ehpad qui en ont pas et
deuxièmement c'est par leur fonction et
c'est véritablement un chantier
considérable que d'améliorer l'accès aux
soins la coordination des soins dans les
ehpad
voilà si les médecins coordinateurs
prescrivait on l'avait demandé mais les
médecins coordinateurs écoutez moi j'ai
deux ehpad dans la sous-préfecture où
j'exerce deux ehpad privé il y en a
aucun qui en est un
parce qu'ils en trouvent pas ce que
j'entrevois mais oui mais c'est la
réalité il y en a non mais écoutez là le
problème là où il y en a un c'est le
choix de chaque patiente de pouvoir
conserver le son médecin traitant connu
parfois depuis vingt ou trente ans c'est
une chose et ensuite un médecin se sont
souvent coordinateur des temps partiels
qui ne sont pas h 24 et je pense qu'il y
à une complémentarité des fonctions et
il faut pas le vivre comme une
superposition sur des champs de
compétences qu'ils soient les mêmes bien
au contraire je crois qu'on a besoin des
uns et des autres et pas d 1 à la place
des autres
[Musique]
le président du cran siens merci oui je
voulais juste peut-être apporter une
précision sur votre question sur est ce
que le confinement était prévisible
notamment en fin janvier février en lien
avec le manque de pays
en fait s'il si le confinement était
prévisible
il n'était certainement pas dû au manque
de pays de pays annoncée puisque à cette
époque je vous rappelle le port du
masque n'était pas
obligatoire ni même recommandé ni même
nécessaire donc en fait ça n'est pas le
manque de pays h plus je peux aussi vous
ressortez les communications de l'époque
enfin fin février oui ça mais ce que je
vais bien sûr mais ça ça on l'a su après
mais est-ce que si on se re non mais ça
ça je suis d'accord avec vous mais je
venais juste pour nous on a été parce
que la question c'est est-ce que nous
nous avons été informés d'un confinement
en raison du manque de pays si nous
avons et si la question du confinement a
été évoquée elle ne nous a pas été
exposées comme lié au manque de pays
puisque on nous disait que oui à ce
moment là je vais préciser ma question
si vous dites n'est pas le manque de
pays je partage l'analyse du président
savary on n'a pas non plus une masque
obligatoire parce que manifestement on
en avait pas de toute façon et nous
aurions été en grande difficulté pour
répondre positivement à cette
prescription mais néanmoins le
confinement général a été évoquée je
voulais savoir ac de ce que j'ai saisie
de ce que vous m'avez dit d'euskadi
messieurs vivre et non mais à quel
moment et pour quels motifs dans ces cas
là on a plus on n'a plus été en contact
après cette réunion du 18 février
donc la question du confinement n'a plus
été entièrement vos décisions
non merci alors est-ce que je continue
c'est les autres questions ou pas
pouvoir continuer oui continuez sur les
autres questions que oui je veux bien
qu'on me précise parce que du coup c'est
un peu un peu perdu dans les réponses
dans les réunions de fin janvier début
février si on va jusqu'au 15 février au
18 février
le confinement n'a pas été évoqué papa
pour des questions de pénurie parce que
est ce qu'on vous a eu d'abord qu'il y
aura une pénurie
non non mais est ce qu'on vous a dit
qu'il y aura une tension sur les
équipements première question et
deuxième question
est-ce que alors indépendamment du un
confinement qui se rallient un manque de
matches ça n'a pas été dit manquer
puisque le sujet n'était pas là
puisqu'on nous et qu'on aime a besoin
est-ce que lors de ses premières
réunions une notion de confinement
hormis peut-être de d'isoler dans le
cadre du cluster est ce que ça avait été
évoquée non c'est bien merci madame à
leur apporter
monsieur je me suis dit oui continuez
sur les réponses on va d'accord donc sur
la question des violences
alors je précise intrafamiliales et pas
que faites aux femmes puisque c'est vrai
qu'il y avait il ya aussi des enfants
qui ont été effectivement victime de
violences donc là je dois je dois
effectivement chronologiquement expliqué
que j'ai été directement contacté à
l'époque par monsieur castaner et que
sans une seconde d'hésitation j'ai
effectivement proposé que les
pharmaciens soient le relais de deux de
ces personnes en détresse
ça a aidé d'ailleurs annoncé le soir
même par le ministre donc présent me
prenant un peu de court parce que
j'avais pas eu le temps du coup de dé
changer mais voilà le principe était
lancée et d'ailleurs les pharmaciens ont
répondu à cette demande alors comment
nous a pas demandé de relever de
statistiques
j'ai pas le chiffre exact de combien de
pharmaciens ont réellement accueillis
mais je peux vous dire qu'on a on a on a
un site le site du cespharm sur lequel
on mettait les documents pour les
pharmaciens pour qui téléchargent la
procédure et cetera il a été très
consulté très télécharger et à titre
personnel moi même dans mon exercice
j'ai accueilli une femme qui était
effectivement visiblement ensuite de son
de son domicile
donc voilà il ya quelques exemples qui
ont été médiatisés peut-être sur les
doigts d'une main
mais je vois là je ne peux pas répondre
précisément
à combien précisément mais je dois dire
que c'est quelque chose que les
pharmaciens font même hors période
qu'ovide le pharmacien est souvent un
confident comme comme beaucoup d'entre
nous professionnels de santé est souvent
voilà on aide déjà rien que l' écoute on
aide mais là c'est vrai que ce
dispositif a permis de donner plus
d'outils aux pharmaciens pour orienter
vers les associations d'aidé aux
victimes vers les avocats et d'ailleurs
derrière ça s'est construit un d'autres
réflexions qui associés d'ailleurs du
coup les autres ordres les sages femmes
les médecins etc et les cabinets et les
ordres d'avocats et c'est pour encore
aller plus loin dans ce dispositif dead
merci les infirmiers merci monsieur
voyage je voulais répondre je pense
madame là en porter et madame la
sénatrice que vous pourriez avoir à
peut-être accès aux comptes rendus qui a
été fait par la dgs qui reprennent les
saf et moi je vais rechercher ma boîte
je sais pas peut-être quelqu'un pourrait
transmettre parce que c'était des
réunions d'information avec beaucoup de
slide et je voudrais pas mouillé en
disant que c'était annoncé
mais effectivement la stratégie
thérapeutique a été fait dans certaines
contrées notamment ewan de confinement
ont été exposés donc après ce qu'on
était trop bête pour comprendre ce que
ça n'avait pas été dit clairement mais
il y avait forcément quelque chose comme
ça pour répondre moi je vais pas
m'opposer aux médecins mais ce n'est pas
l'objet je presse connaît plutôt
complémentaires mais sur les ehpad
effectivement la découverte les
municipales qui avait pas de médecine
mais nous ça fait dix ans qu'on prône
pour que dans les ehpad les homos des
infirmiers on ne veut pas le jour on
parle la nuit simplement parce que je
vais rappeler qu'il ya pas d'infirmière
à unia les pales et ça c'est quand même
un manque qu on a refait valoir au ségur
et pour boucler avec la sénatrice jasper
effectivement dans les hypers et l'a61
inscrits est un notable de l'ordre qu'on
est en phase de déploiement 60 diplômés
cette année on n'a pas les effectifs
nécessaires pour pouvoir les déployer
mais peut-être effectivement que les
infimes pratiques avancées notamment une
spécialité qui n'existe pas mais qui
pourrait être porté sur la prochaine loi
grand âge
les porcs qui va être porté par un homme
bourguignon par le ministre
bourguignonne pourrait voir cette
spécialité ou pas arrivé et pouvoir être
utile dans l'est dans les ehpad moi j'ai
entendu teurs quelque chose alors je pas
là pour faire une des bagnes pour
favoriser ou dévaloriser un ordre
d'abord concernant les crs à moi je
pense que tous les autres devraient être
présents et on voit bien la
complémentarité de chacun ici présents
alors que nous ne sommes pas dans le
texte réglementaire qui fondent les crs
à sur uniquement représenté les médecins
c'est pas je veux pas débattre avec vous
madame la sénatrice mais c'est juste
sache pas ce qu'on voit bien la
complémentarité et si le président
savary nous a fait venir c'est que
chacun détient un bout de la vérité de
la prise en charge des patients et je
pense que à ce titre là l'organisation
ne peut pas se faire moi j'ai besoin la
prescription du métier et j'ai besoin
que le pharmacien me délivrer le
médicament pour faire des sous et donc
on voit bien qu'il ya une réalité qui
n'est pas actuellement dans les
instances de délibération de proximité
régionale ou de dt ars qui va diffuser
pour permettre justement cette prise en
charge optimale des passeurs d'autant
plus conditions de prise en charge de
ville et on voit bien la confiance et
qui a été fait à la ville parce que on
parle beaucoup des prises en charge
hospitalière
mais le plus gros des troupes des
patients qui ont été sauvées et soigné
on était en ville il faut quand même
remettre chaud sur les étagères il ya eu
38 décès c'est très malheureux mais
beaucoup de gens sont sortis et ont été
pris en charge en bus donc en fait je
pense que fait l'ordre effectivement on
a des textes qui sont très contraint
mais on a été là pour représenter les
professionnels pour les soutenir pour
agir pour eux pour les entrées des pour
les écouter pour remplir des missions
que finalement personne n'a fait alors
que c'était des personnes qui étaient en
première ligne tous les professionnels
santé ont été en première ligne
et justement ont réussi et on a maintenu
parce que ça peut être c'est passé un
peu sous les radars
quelquefois des passes des praticiens
qui se disait ce que j'y viens ce que
j'y vais pas parce que le manque de pays
certes a été clair pour la totalité mais
pour les professionnels qui sont obligés
d'aller au combat passé étaient les
termes de prix pour la prochaine
république mais de soigner les patients
à proximité c'est quand même une réalité
il ya quelquefois eu des doutes sur
lesquels on est obligé de téléphoner ou
deux
des écrits justement pour expliquer un
peu la doctrine sur des épidémies moment
exceptionnel qui s'est passé pour la
france et dans le monde sur lesquels
j'ai quelquefois les principes éthiques
et déontologiques ont pu tong merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup monsieur le
président pour répondre aux différentes
questions qui m'ont été posées
la première concerne les maisons de
naissance et sont elles une alternative
à la situation de crise je ne
souhaiterais pas à ramener les maisons
de naissance à une approche réductrice
concernant une épidémie les maisons de
naissance elles sont expérimentés évalué
nous attendons au jour d'aujourd'hui
leur généralisation
effectivement pour répondre à votre
question sur le fond plus cultes en
alternative elles sont aussi des espaces
de proximité
fondée sur le choix des femmes en termes
d'orientation face à une situation pour
la population les plus grands clusters
français ont été les hôpitaux et les
maternités résident la plupart du temps
dans les hôpitaux
effectivement nous avons eu de
nombreuses inquiétudes concernant les
freins de la population à rentrer à
l'hôpital pour être moi-même
inhospitalière j'ai vu les locaux de
l'hôpital de la maternité désaffectée
par les femmes
suite au public aux publications public
mentionnant qu'il ne fallait se déplacer
que lorsqu'on était très malade sur la
justification des déplacements et les
modalités la pertinence des modalités
justificatifs met en place pour les
déplacements de la population
je ne suis pas en mesure de répondre à
cette question sur l'échelle
populationnelle ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que au delà d'un visibiliser les
sages femmes les publications parfois
contradictoires aussi un visibiliser les
femmes et la santé des femmes
ce qui fait que certains sages femmes
ont connu un pour un certain nombre des
difficultés de leurs déplacements
professionnels
mais les femmes aussi de surcroît au
connu de véritables difficultés dans
leurs déplacements
pas seulement pour des barrières de la
langue ou de l'édition du papier mais
tout simplement parce que elle était
interrompu dans leurs déplacements parce
que pour les pouvoirs publics
il n'était pas justifié de se déplacer
par exemple pour les demandes
contraceptive
alors que sans contraception c'est une
grossesse non désirée
concernant la situation sanitaire des
sages femmes que vous évoquez dans votre
hôpital qui a été catastrophique et la
communication désordre je voudrais aussi
préciser qu'en dehors de fait d'être des
élus ordinaux nous sommes les
professionnels de santé
donc nous sommes très très hauts faits
parce que directement appliquée par les
conditions que vous avez évoquées et je
voudrais rappeler que le communication
elles ont été nombreuses
aussi bien vers les pouvoirs vers les
pouvoirs publics que vers les médias
elles ont aussi nous avons joué un rôle
d' alerte nous avons aussi au prix avec
la phase épidémique
anouk ont posé sur un rôle différent que
celui qui nous étaient attribués
préalablement mais de surcroît nous
avons aussi une communication inédite
sur lequel vous nous avez interrogé qui
est notre tribune du 30 avril
et là je crois que c'est un fait sans
précédent où tous les ordres se sont
rassemblés pour communiquer alerter sur
les masques de protection concernant la
la situation et la préparation à la
presse et la communication d ordre est
ce que les ordres réclame sur la suite
je crois que il me semble avoir été
clair dans les propos liminaires et
d'avoir été alerté sur la situation en
tout cas de la périnatalité la situation
de la santé des femmes en france il y à
des actions à mener les actions à mener
ça doit être en tout cas pour ma
profession obtenir enfin des masques
ffp2 au jour d'aujourd'hui je le dis
publiquement les sages femmes continuent
à exercer avec des patients qui sont co
vie de plus sans masque de protection
adaptées l'autre élément je crois qu'il
est absolument important de se focaliser
sur des éléments tels que la mène et
telle la télémédecine la question qui a
été soulevée est partagé on voit bien
qu'ici nous avons eu une dimension
sensuelle un terreau ordinale sur des
actions de santé a mené collectivement
enfin je voulais rappeler comme je lé
précisant les propos liminaires une
femme enceinte n'est pas malade
mon collègue responsable de l'ordre des
médecins a évoqué la difficulté pour les
citoyens en mauvaise santé de réfléchir
à la pertinence de leur déplacement vers
un cabinet médical de surcroît une femme
enceinte n'est pas mal
une femme qui souhaite une contraception
ou qui souhaitent avoir accès à ces âges
in écologie de prévention n'est pas
malade
donc effectivement nous considérons que
les femmes ont été relativement sains
visibiliser dans la dimension
pandémique qu'a connu la france monsieur
fournier pour les dentistes
oui merci monsieur le président
concernant le problème des masques et
pour essayer d'être claires à la
question posée par nos sénatrice
rapporteur il est évident que
l'impression que l'on a à la fin de
l'histoire c'est que les services de
l'état ont essayé de cacher le plus
longtemps possible y compris aux
professionnels de santé et y compris aux
corps intermédiaires l'absence de
moyenne de protection et notamment de
masques que ce soit ait fait 2 ou voir
même chirurgicale ce qui nous amène ce
qui m'amène est évidemment j'entends des
reproches larvée de la part de cette
dame journaliste je pense non une
sénatrice
j'entends les reproches larvée me disant
vous avez fait fermer les cabinets mais
quand le lundi 16 mars à 17 heures jeux
fait fermer les cabinets trois heures
avant l'intervention du président de la
république qui confine les français à 20
heures nous avons quelque part les mêmes
raisons à part que mon jeu viennent de
découvrir qu'on n'a pas un masque en
réserve en france aujourd'hui et
quelques heures après le ministère nous
octroie cent mille masques ffp2 il faut
savoir que la consommation par semaine
et de 800 mille masques en france pour
l'ensemble des charges dentiste on nous
en donne 100 milles ce qui nous
permettra de faire fonctionner pendant
un mois
les cabinets de garde judicieusement
répartis par département sur l'ensemble
du territoire
certes on a eu ces cent mille masques au
début mais je pense que pour nous donner
ces cent mille ffp2 je crois que l'état
a raclé les tiroirs puisque j'ai
l'impression et j'ai un petit peu honte
de le dire aujourd'hui mais sur le
moment on n'en n'a pas fait plus que ça
la publicité parce que nous savions que
dans les hôpitaux que nos amis médecins
dans les cabinets libéraux les nos amis
pharmaciens infirmiers et tous les
autres professionnels de santé n'en
avait pas certes nous sommes les plus
exposés
donc nous avons été doté mais nous avons
été dotés et je le découvre à la fin de
l'histoire qu'en fait on n'a pas de sens
voilà moi je suis pas là sens des
responsables dont
chirurgicaux que nous avons dans les
cabinets dentaires ne sont pas adaptés à
l'état de crise puisque ne peut
travailler qu'avec du sp 2 renouvelé
deux fois par jour etc etc
donc ces masques là nous n'en disposons
parce ça c'est en ce qui concerne donc
le thème la sénatrice c'est en ce qui
concerne le problème des masques
vous avez soulevé l'allongement des
délais et là nous sommes dans un
processus totalement mécanique à savoir
qu'un cabinet moyens reçoit 20 patients
par jour et aujourd'hui n'en reçoit plus
qu'un par heure en travaillant dix
heures par jour cela veut dire qu'il
réduit son activité mécaniquement de 50%
donc les délais d'attentes selon les
régions vont être grosse x 2 e
il est il y a deux sujets là dessus on
m'a demandé de diminuer
là le comment dire le côté coercitives
des recommandations que nous avons fait
on est on a fait une version 3d
recommandation 'alléger' certes mais en
gardant la sécurité du patient du
personnel des cabinets dentaires et du
praticien
donc on ne pourra pas aller en dessous
par contre j'ai demandé vivement mais
46000 confrères de bien vouloir
augmenter leur temps de travail car il
me semble que c'est possible
notamment chez les jeunes générations
qui n'ont pas forcément l'habitude de
travailler six jours par semaine
donc j'ai demandé au cabinet dentaire
d'augmenter le temps de travail afin de
diminuer le temps de prise de rendez
vous en ce qui concerne le forfait
qu'ovide ce fameux dépassement il est
bien évident que nous sommes très clairs
au niveau de l'ordre national il ne peut
pas y avoir de dépassement sauvage entre
guillemets
concernant un forfait qu'ovide pour des
soins conventionnés ces dépassements
peuvent exister sur des soins en
horaires libres mais je ne vois pas
comment sur un patient cmu comment
va-t-on pouvoir appliquer un forfait
qu'ovide forfaits dépassements commis
sur un patient cmu donc sur les
honoraires libres à condition que cet
affichage soit affichée que c'est que ce
dépassement soit affichée mis sur le
site soumis à un devis préalable nous
pouvons l'accepter parce que hélas c'est
la réalité du terrain est qu'aujourd'hui
dans un cabinet dentaire
les fournitures de protection représente
un budget considérable qui à terme si
nous n'avons pas dead de l'assurance
maladie comme ça devait être le cas
puisqu'il était question d'avoir un
forfait négocier avec des syndicats
et puis ce forfait a disparu des
négociations donc aujourd'hui il faut
savoir que nous sommes mais nous sommes
seuls face face donc à ce problème
voilà la position de l'ordre est très
clair il n'est pas question d'appliquer
ou plus défavorisés ou pour des soins
simples bien que le matériel de
protection soit le même je ne vois pas
là nous sommes sur la vente de blancs
chez nous je suis en train de jouer
numéro d'équilibriste un peu compliqué
merci madame mathieu merci monsieur
résident plusieurs choses sur les
réunions dont on n'a que l'on a évoqué à
la dgs en janvier et après on nous a
remis des diaporamas en effet et moi
j'ai eu l'impression que on découvrait
on nous a d'abord évoqué ce qui se
passait en chine
on nous a donné des chiffres et je pense
en toute bonne foi où on nous disons que
c'était très contagieux mais peu
mortelle et je pense que peut-être aussi
nous avions des chiffres qui n'était pas
la réalité on l'a bien vu après avec les
incinérateurs en chine et est ce qui
s'est passé dans
on est partis déjà d'un postulat qui
était faux au départ mais à mon sens en
tout cas en toute bonne foi et je me
souviens de cette première réunion où
avait été évoqué d'abord le fait de
traiter les patients à l'hôpital puis
quand le nombre de patients seraient
trop importants si on n'arrivait pas à
juguler l'épidémie de les traiter à
domicile en confinement mais les
patients confinés à domicile mais en
aucun cas on ne nous a parlé de
confinement généralisé de la population
moi j'ai gardé les diaporamas je les ai
revu récemment pour refaire un petit peu
l'historique et ça n'a pas du tout été
évoquée en ce qui nous concerne
d'ailleurs peut-être que ça nous aurait
permis d'anticiper aussi vis-à-vis de
nos membres et de nous organiser mieux
mais je pense que ça n'était tout
simplement pas dans les tuyaux si je
peux m'exprimer ainsi de
l'administration en tout cas vous nous
les frais parvenir ce diaporama d'y
assurer 100 avec leur date nous permet
de bien sûr bien sûr et d'ailleurs
participé des virologues des gens de
l'institut pasteur enfin tout ce que la
france a depuis haute autorité
scientifique en la matière en matière de
virologie d'épidémie voilà et c'était
des réunions très intéressant mais plus
informative sur la souffrance des
professionnels madame la sénatrice
vraiment merci parce que vous dites que
nous vous ne nous avez pas entendu à ce
propos c'est vrai parce qu'on a répondu
à des questions et puis on a
l'impression d'être un peu loin de cette
phase aiguë alors et on en est très
proche finalement même si le quotidien a
repris un petit peu le dessus
les professionnels d'abord on était très
angoissée et une véritable angoisse que
vivait la profession bien sûr mais la
population et si bien qu'on recevait
toutes ces informations contradictoires
parce qu'on ne savait rien finalement et
tout le monde avait peur on avait tous
de toute façon des proches des gens âgés
donc il y avait cette angoisse aussi de
l'avenir cette angoisse financière pour
les kinésithérapeutes en tout cas qui a
généré beaucoup d'agressivité parfois où
on a eu vraiment des comportements
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux assez
difficile à gérer
et quand je vous disais c'est s ancre le
nombre de 2,2
mail auquel nous avons dû répondre en
permanence et très souvent moi je
demandais aux personne ne veut donner
leur numéro de téléphone et je lui ai
rappelé mes jeux parfois je passais 4 5
heures par jour à parler avec des
professionnels et c'était la même chose
dans les départements donc on a été au
plus près des professionnels mais où il
y avait beaucoup de questions beaucoup
d'angoissé dans une profession en plus
et vous le disiez qui est en souffrance
de toute façon en ce moment elle est en
souffrance par un manque de
reconnaissance et vous l'avez ce millier
souligné et d'ailleurs moi je vois avec
grand plaisir
la plupart des professions autour de moi
évoluer parce que la santé évolue la
prise en charge de la population évolue
pardon et donc je me réjouis de voir de
nouvelles compétences pour les
formations pour les infirmiers pour les
sages-femmes
mais je déplore que toutes les demandes
que je demande pour ma profession ne
soit jamais entendu et je ne me
l'expliqué pas
je ne me l'expliqué pas et donc si vous
voulez les professionnels et
kinésithérapeutes ne se l'expliquent pas
non plus voient leurs compétences
distribué à d'autres professions et ne
savent plus du tout sur quel pied danser
est ce que l'avenir leur réserve et
c'est une véritable préoccupation est
comme quand je vous dis que j'ai écrit
partout je vous écris à vous j'ai écrit
au député j'écris au ministre et je n'ai
pas de réponse je n'ai pas de réponse
mais j'y reviendrai en tout cas sur les
ehpad sur les ehpad
on a parlé les médecins coordonnateurs
moi je déplore vraiment le fait que les
administratifs prennent le pas sur les
médecins et les professionnels de santé
dans les ehpad
quand je vois et j'ai beaucoup de mails
à ce propos j'en avais amené
quelques-uns là que le médecin
coordonnateur demande à ce qu'il y ait
des kinésithérapeutes rédige la
prescription appelle lui-même le
kinésithérapeute et que le directeur des
pas de refuser l'entrée moi je ne
comprends pas j'avais même demandé au
ministère si on ne pouvait pas alors
c'était peut-être illusoire envisagée
une absence de responsabilité pénale des
directeurs d'ehpad parce que leurs
craintes en fait c'est d'être accusé de
mise en danger d'autrui si on fait
entrer des gens dans les ehpad et
d'ailleurs au mois de janvier quand les
ehpad ont commencé à refuser les
kinésithérapeutes bien avant le
confinement que j'avais alerté le
ministère et que j'avais alerté les
fédérations d pad le ministère m'avait
dit que ce n'était pas du tout leurs
consignes mais que les ehpad était
particulièrement inquiet parce que et ça
revient ce que disait jean-marcel
mourgues en fait c'est qu'ils avaient
peur que le système de santé ne puisse
pas tenir s'il y avait un afflux trop
important de patients et le ministère
m'avait dit s'il y a trop de patients
dans les hôpitaux
à un moment on sera peut-être amené à
devoir trier et dans les ehpad
on ne pourra pas forcément les mettre en
réanimation parce que la durée en
réanimation
c'est au moins trois semaines
quelquefois quatre cinq six semaines et
donc avoir des personnes âgés
polypathologiques susceptible
d'encombrés entre guillemets des lits
d'hôpitaux et de ne pas pouvoir intégrer
les jeunes ça les inquiète et je dis pas
qu'ils aient eu du triage mais c'est
pour cette raison qu'on a limité l'accès
aux et pas très tôt y compris pour des
soins qui sont pour moi essentiel et je
pense qu'on n'a pas fini d'en payer les
conséquences les personnes âgées en tout
cas parce que ce genre de situation se
reproduira il se reproduit déjà
maintenant s'agissant des
kinésithérapeutes dans les ehpad
évidemment on en revient aussi à la
qualité des soins peut-être je voulais
juste vous dire que le maintien de
l'autonomie d'une personne âgée en ehpad
ses côtés 12 euros 60 brut
ça veut dire qu'il reste 6 euros 10 on a
48 % de charges avant impôts au
kinésithérapeute pour s'occuper d'une
personne âgée
alors en effet ça n'est pas rentable
surtout si on veut passer trois quarts
d'heure pour faire un bon travail
donc là devra se poser la question de
ces rémunérations sur le
les consignes diverses oui vous avez
raison madame la sénatrice et gelé moi
même déplorer et je m'en suis moi même
expliqué c'est à dire que l'ordre a
donné des consignes en responsabilité
parce que nous n'avions pas d'équipement
parce que les conditions d'hygiène dans
les cabinets sont très difficiles
on n'est pas dans la situation des
infirmiers qui font la majorité de leurs
soins à domicile libero je parle et très
peu à leur cabinet on n'est pas dans le
cadre des médecins mais on a beaucoup de
cabinets pluri professionnelle avec
beaucoup de praticiens et c'est
d'ailleurs ce que veut le gouvernement
et est la représentation nationale
peut-être on nous demande de nous
regrouper
la ministre avait dit plus d'exercices
individuel donc dans un cabinet vous
avez quatre kinésithérapeutes avec des
salles individuelles en effet mais des
salles communes
quand on sait que quand on on
projette à au moins cinq mètres au
niveau respiratoire
si vous avez plusieurs patients à la
fois parce que vous avez plusieurs
professionnels plus les accompagnons
parce qu'il faut savoir que dans nos
cabinets la plupart des patients ne
peuvent pas conduire quand vous êtes
opéré d'un genou d'une épaule vous vous
faite accompagner ou par un proche ou
par quelqu'un donc ça fait un monde
considérable dans les salles d'attenté
dans les salles de soins qui ne nous ont
pas laissé d'autre choix en début de
crise est actuellement les consignes
d'hygiène sont très strictes
mais je ne vois pas comment on pourrait
faire autrement
de ce fait ça limite le nombre de
patients accueillis et sa limite aussi
les rues mais rémunération et nous
sommes aussi inquiet pour la santé
économique de nos de nos confrères et je
terminerai peut-être en disant que sur
les masques
il ya eu de grosses difficultés
d'approvisionnement parce que les
pharmaciens ont été en première ligne et
ça n'a pas été facile pour eux ça j'en
avais parlé à karine wolf talent
justement pour lui dire moi dans mon
officine ou le pharmacien est un ami
pendant trois semaines en début de crise
je n'ai pas eu de masques
je n'avais pas ma dotation tout
simplement parce que lui n'en avait pas
et il a été je suis ensuite gironde plus
trois semaines consécutives sans
recevoir de masquer tout au début
si bien que moi j'arrive et je râlais
mais tous les autres professionnels de
santé évidemment on lui dément fin mais
comment ça se fait mais c'est pas
possible tu les as donné au médecin est
pas moins voilà ce qu il entendait et ça
a été j'avoue très compliqué pour les
pharmaciens est très compliqué pour les
professionnels c'est pour ça que l'ordre
a commandé des visières qui ne se
substitue pas au masque bien évidemment
mais nous avons fourni en visière très
solide et de qualité pour doubler ça
évite aussi de toucher le masque et ça
permet d'avoir un peu plus de sécurité
quand même dans nos soins et puis bien
suite à la crise on nous a dit ce sera
plus jamais comme avant il va y avoir le
ségur et ça va être le grand soir et
finalement je n'ai qu'un regret c'est
que pour la kinésithérapie et la
rééducation général il n'y a rien eu
je n'ai pas du tout été entendu et
finalement la rééducation c'est la
grande absente des politiques publiques
dans ce pays où on ne parle que peu de
prévention mais jamais de rééducation et
de réadaptation
on est dans le soin et c'est pour ça
aussi je pense que nous sommes souvent
les grands oubliés parce que et c'est
invisible et nous sommes invisibles
parce que on n'imagine pas alors quand
on travaille avec un chirurgien
orthopédiste il sait très bien que s'il
opère une épaule sans kinésithérapie il
n'y aura pas de bons résultats ça les
médecins avec qui nous travaillons le
savent mais les pouvoirs publics très
souvent me semble-t-il n'en sont pas
conscients merci beaucoup
nous avons encore une salve de questions
michon voilà pour cette audition au
sénat des différentes professions de
santé qui ont été mobilisés au printemps
dernier au plus fort de la crise du
coroner virus
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi prochain rendez vous
demain à 11 heures pour une nouvelle
audition de la commission d'enquêté du
sénat sur la gestion de cette crise de
lakovic 19
je vous souhaite une très bonne soirée
sur public sénat
nous
[Musique]